ben
did ilhan omar marry her brother
the evidence speaks for itself
bottom line
so you're saying you think yeah she
won't speak about it right she will call
you an islamophobic bigot as this her
want in the kind of progressive or bigot
binary uh she uses that as a shield and
a weapon to go after anyone who would
dare
seek out the truth but look like you
wrote a book about her didn't you i did
yeah i wrote a book called american
ingrid as the least provocative title
that i could think of
all right all right we'll get we'll get
into all that i just had to open with
that because uh we have the story
that i don't look i don't it's a guy
making a claim right this is this is a
crazy crazy story a political operative
has uh claims
that they have dna evidence they got
from illidan omar's cigarette that
proves she married her brother well i
don't i don't know about all that i
think there's a whole bunch of other
circumstantial evidence that you know
gives you pause to the extent that even
the star tribune which is a pulitzer
prize winning paper in in minnesota uh
they said that this man was possibly her
brother like they actually entertained
the possibility i'm not
we'll talk about the story but this work
it's crazy 12 hours i guess after the
dude releases this supposed dna evidence
he gets arrested on a federal indictment
for child trafficking now i'm not sure i
trust this
but innocent until proven guilty
although it's a pretty
crazy allegation and i'll tell you this
grand juries don't happen overnight so
if this was 12 hours after he released
this they must have been going after him
for some time now
we'll read the story it's a crazy story
we got a bunch of other news we got 63
people from obama's birthday party got
coveted i guess and so uh yeah there you
go but uh la la palooza seem to be fine
and man parents are fighting uh with
teachers and school board over mass
mandates and stuff's getting creepy then
we got afghanistan we got a whole bunch
of news and you know we're going to
round it off with something really
interesting culturally suicide squad
have you seen it yet it's bombing
and
it's crazy to all all these people
saying it was a great movie but we're
not here to talk necessarily about the
the pop culture elements of the movie
although i'd love to do that too
something's happening to our culture
it's like movies don't matter anymore
like it's it's a fracture and now you
got joe biden
discussing mandatory vaccinations for
interstate travel
what would happen to this country if
they implement something like that
fractures in two seconds so uh obviously
uh ben do you want to introduce yourself
because you i already you know put you
on the spot with that lead in um yeah
don't associate me with ilana omar
please
but that said yeah ben weingarten i'm a
deputy editor at real quick
investigations a senior contributor of
the federalist i write for newsweek epic
times and a whole bunch of other places
um frequently about u.s china policy but
also
the kind of woke i call it an
anti-cultural revolution that we're
going through uh part of that that i've
been focused on a lot lately is january
6th all things around january 6 and how
that is sort of
the essential event that all of the
scaffolding has been built around to
engage in the kind of war on wrong think
that we're seeing play out in every
single sphere of american society today
so all sorts of fun very optimistic and
positive stuff yeah right on we gotta we
got ian yeah when i when i learned
started to learn about the reichstag in
hitler's nazi early days of nazi germany
where the reichstag their parliament
building burned down and and they he
blamed the communists and then used that
as authority to ban civil rights take
away people's rights and then start
going after people so i'm very
very like
on edge about these kind of things like
this january 6th thing it makes me
very enabling act yeah you got to watch
out for for swift
pointing at something and then doing a
bunch of laws as a result
man it's sad because it seems like
people don't learn the the the national
security apparatus has for years been
talking about domestic violence
extremists and specifically
you know they'll use a million different
adjectives but right white nationalists
right-wing white supremacists etc and
they didn't have an event that they
could glom onto to accelerate what they
already would have wanted to achieve in
terms of
targeting their political adversaries
and then using that to increase their
power over them this was the
precipitating event but the thing is
every element of the narrative around
january 6th has really collapsed it was
it's a joke to think of that it was an
insurrection these people were not going
to no one's been charged with it the the
crimes are for the most part and there
were people who did egregious things no
question about it and you know there's
reports of you know a per an officer had
his eye gouged and and all sorts of
other horrible assaults and the like but
the majority of the charges put out
against the almost 600 people now were
basically glorified trumped up
trespassing charges
um and the only person who died of
course relating to the event
specifically was ashley babbitt being
shot it wasn't officer sicknick getting
bludgeoned with a fire extinguisher did
not happen it did not happen um pretty
much every element of the narrative and
then you compare it to what happened
during the george floyd riots or even
you compared to
uh the 2017 there was inauguration riots
in dc that people don't really talk
about a lot which actually might serve
as a template for how the government
tries to go after the j600
i want to add one more thing that a lot
of our listeners have have already heard
me say but just for you did you know
that uh
civics polling shows that democrats
think the economy is doing fairly well
if you laugh because it's like wow what
like the consumer price index is higher
than it's been in 13 years there's more
the job openings are escalating 4
million people resigned gas prices are
through the roof
the people who follow the media they
watch cnn
they if they heard what you just said
right now about january 6th he's lying
because they don't actually know what's
happening in the real world but we'll
get into all this stuff we got we got
lydia over here she's present i am
pressing buttons in the corner and the
j6 stuff is really interesting to me as
well because i was watching a segment i
think it was from msnbc earlier today
where they were saying that not only was
january 6th an insurgency we're all
insurgents like conservatives are
insurgents i'm like that's probably not
a good thing to introduce into the
dialogue but i'm hoping we can get into
it and you need a counter-insurgency
policy today exactly
so they've war on domestic terrorists
anyway i'm excited i'm honored because
apparently there was a hit piece that
claimed i was the most dangerous uh
political commentator uh as they said on
the right because i feign impartiality
but i'm anything but and it's really
funny because like
if does that is that you saying you
actually don't have anything to
criticize me over like my political
opinions because it seems like i'm
mostly just about letting people live
their own lives i mean there's a real
value to neutral authority
i think that's you know if anything if
you're pioneering neutrality in
authority that's that's valid and useful
it's not so much about neutrality it's
about like
you know people standing up for their
individual uh liberties and things like
that you know the thing is but your
individual one person's individual
liberty is another person's assault on
everyone else yeah but those are
crackpots like if you're if you're
saying you know i wanna
have uh
like my own space to live and do my
thing and defend myself and then someone
says you shouldn't be allowed to have a
weapon to defend yourself in your own
home it's like
well now you're intruding on someone's
home it's the same argument when they
say when they were talking about you
know gay marriage and stuff back in the
day when they were like what people do
in their own home is their business i'm
like that's right if you got a gun and a
bazook i don't care just don't bring it
over to my property like i don't want
that on my property but if you want to
have that in your place i don't care
whatever what's changed is that there
were people who you would say liberal
and and truly left a liberal not
classical liberal but it used to be in
this country i think a strong majority
would have said live and let live we
disagree on a whole host of different
issues however we have a few things that
we agree on that transcend all of them
now it's you either agree with us or
we're going to send an invading army
digital or otherwise well it's like it's
like mayo gate yeah where the where the
regular guy just made a comment about my
prices are going up and then all these
these leftist publications are sending a
harassment campaign his way it's crazy
well let's let's jump to the news before
we get started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member and you will
get an advertisement free experience
experience on all of our wonderful
fierce and independent journalism
as well as access to our members only
segments and we got uh two new shows in
the works should be coming very very
soon these things just take time man i
wish we could just snap our fingers and
have everything up and running but you
know we've got all these different crews
we do have the vlog which is up you can
check that out at
cast castle but also
just uh if you want to support our work
and we're hiring more journalists we're
starting a fact-checking non-profit
which will be on the side and uh uh it's
gonna be great
so let's just uh don't forget to like
this video subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends let's
get weird with it it's friday night we
like to be weird on fridays
from the daily mail exclusive is this
the proof that ilhan omar married her
own brother to bypass us immigration
rules conservative group's dna test from
congresswoman cigarette butt purports to
show 99.99
match to her second husband ahmed almi
and so they show this photo of illinois
smoking a cigarette and i guess that's
like supposed to be proof that big tent
republican pak i guess
secured the cigarette after the fact and
then did a dna test on it and then you
end up with this dna siblingship report
which is claiming what do they say it's
like a 99
okay they say the result of the test
assert that there is a 99 point oh man
i'm going to read this nine nine nine
nine nine eight percent chance that omar
and her second husband ahmed elmi are
siblings the report drawn up by endeavor
dna laboratories does not name either
omar or elmi instead referring to them
as sibling one and sibling two
it says that sibling one sample was
garnered from a cigarette butt and and
sibling two is from a drinking straw
you know what's really funny is that we
talked about this like a year or so ago
where it was like we were joking because
there's an episode of law and order
where like they're trying to bust this
guy and they can't get the evidence and
then he drinks from a coffee and then
throws the cup in the dumpster or like
into a trash and they walk up and pick
it up with like tongs and they're like
discarded materials and they're like hey
you can't do that and then they get the
dna evidence and i was like what if
somebody just like found an old snot rag
and then randy and i improved
i'm not i'm not sure i believe
you know people went out and actually
did this i'm not i think it's kind of
outlandish i don't know what else
someone would do like if you're trying
to prove this but i'll tell you where it
gets really really crazy here's what
they say
the test was posted online by anton
lazzaro a republican strategist in
minneapolis on wednesday around 12 hours
later lazzaro was arrested on federal
child trafficking charges or i'm sorry
isn't it isn't a child on uh
i'm being careful because it's youtube
trafficking but they they did say under
18 uh was was part of it so it's trap
yeah okay it does say child right child
trafficking
he's currently he is now in custody
awaiting a hearing on monday
i wonder how many people are screaming
it's a conspiracy
he was about to bust el hanomar or maybe
he's a shady guy and he does shady
things and this is
complete bs evidence
i guess outside of any of these dna
claims there's circumstantial evidence
that leads many people to believe she
married her brother because it was it
was to get him in the country right yeah
it was an immigration thing and then he
got to go to school and so you have
multiple layers of potential fraud in
terms of the immigration fraud the
student loan fraud and probably other
misrepresentation
as well and the circumstantial evidence
is
very compelling here let's jump to that
but first i want to show people listen i
am i'm not saying i know anything
definitively i'm saying people have made
these assertions there have been bits of
circumstantial evidence to the point
that star tribune a pulitzer prize
winning paper reported in june twenty on
june 23 2019 new documents revisit
questions about rep ilhan omar's
marriage history although she has
legally corrected the discrepancy she
has declined to say anything about how
or why it happened they say
new investigative documents released by
a state agency have given fresh like
life to lingering questions about the
marital history of rep ilhan omar and
whether she once married a man possibly
her own brother to skirt immigration
laws now if if there was
i'll say this either star treatment is
extremely reckless
by saying it was possibly her brother or
there is circumstantial evidence many
people have seen which say
yeah that might have been a brother
right and also the star tribune is sort
of the house democrat party paper
in the area they were very favorable
towards illinois the whole way i mean
she was like the perfect progressive
sort of avatar for minneapolis
so yeah you go in you can look at the
marriage certificate you can look at the
addresses that she was living in with
the alleged brother husband at the same
time her actual
husband was living in like the same
place you know you can run through all
of these different threads
two things jump out at me though and one
of the reasons i wrote this book is
because
the brother husband thing was like the
least of the potential issues that i saw
in her i said if you actually look at
her on the merits the regressive
ideology that she harbors the fact that
she was sitting on the house foreign
affairs committee which he still sits on
and if you apply the russian collusion
standard or any collusion standard her
lynx ties coordination with foreign
adversaries what i found and sort of the
starting point for the book was
she has ties to erdogan in turkey
substantial ties when she was a state
legislator she had a meeting with
erdogan on the sideline of un general
assembly what state legislator from
minnesota as a remember when she said uh
we should sanction israel because of
human right abuses but then said
sanctioning turkey would be a human
rights abuse a lot of people were like
hey does she speak the language turkish
she doesn't i don't believe she speaks
the language but she is featured in
turkish state media all the time she's
had meetings with several dignitaries
from turkey always taking a pro turkish
wine turkey has relations with close
relations with somalia so i do think
that that is a part of this as well that
she is pro-turkish in large part because
of that
and that's not even to get into like all
of the domestic islamist groups and
individuals you know and the
anti-semitism so oh yeah that we didn't
even get to that yeah right right right
so this is what bugs me about this is
this is a
a problem with the democratic party at
large ilhan omar did what i would refer
to as crop dusting anti-semitism you
know like crop master planes get like
real close to the ground they don't
touch it so she was saying like you know
she said it's all about the benjamins
she said you know multiple like dual
loyalties and stuff like that and those
are typically more more aggressive those
tropes are used more aggressively in
direct anti-semitic attacks so she
didn't directly make it about being
jewish but she you know she crop dusted
the ideas and it got a lot of people
angry and instead of doing anything
about it the multiple things more than
just you know that a lot of people think
she was overtly anti-semitic they just
say we're going to denounce all forms of
bigotry and she's allowed to keep her
positions and do whatever she wants the
republicans would set their own on fire
in two seconds like they've done with
marjorie taylor greene it was uh was it
steve king i think he made that tweet
about white nationalism they kicked him
out immediately and they lost his
primary because republicans are like we
don't want none of that the democrats
though they're like who cares you know
when i'll tell you this it's because of
the media
because and that's there's another thing
here that's why republicans care more
about the opinion of the new york times
than the opinion of their constituents
because the republicans know
if they fart it'll be the headline paper
on the new york times and the democrats
know they can do and say basically
anything and the papers will not cover
you got aoc being able to tweet tweet it
out and it's more popular than the new
york times like she has 6 million
followers i think no no she has like 12
or 13 12 million followers on twitter
alone
part of the thesis of the book was that
the closing ranks around omar to go from
explicitly condemning omar and her
remarks to we're going to explicitly
condemn bigotry of any kind that anyone
has ever said and not name her in the
house resolution or resolutions around
it that was the turning point which
showed you that the democrat party is
all in and embracing the regressive
progressives because either they think
that that's where the party is going and
that's where the power is or the party's
already there and i was writing this a
couple years ago and they're there i
would say right now the other thing
worth noting just on the media point
briefly tangentially is why is it always
that it's just the daily mail that
reports on hunter biden and elon omer
notice how there are no domestic
publications that ever delve into any of
these things i mean with rare exceptions
as you know the new york post obviously
with hunter biden but that said why do
you have to go to the daily mail to get
your news about ilhon omar isn't that
kind of strange yeah you know what's
fascinating too is uh
daily mail is not bad uh the left hates
them and they're always acting like it's
it's fake news or whatever but they
typically have some of the most
comprehensive breakdowns of news stories
you'll find they have four or five
thousand words on a single story that
the hill will have 300 on and then and
then they'll attach you know related
stories with like background information
i'm i'm i'm rather impressed by that
it's a british company
yeah it's murdock too right i think so i
think so and and they had people on the
ground for illinois there were like
three journalists in the country maybe
who were looking at her and they were
dogged in covering the omar beat i was a
big fan of al jazeera getting my middle
east uh news because i would read a lot
of american propaganda and then i'd go
and read al jazeera and see like oh
there's a lot more going on than what
i'm getting fed by the american media
mainstream media is um what's what i'm
thinking of um refuse
debris debris flotsam
most of it well there's like bits of
gold in the in the sewage and you're
like how do i get it out but it's so
effective though the hysteria i'm sure
we'll talk about the coronavirus stuff
but the oh yeah
hysteria engendered around it where we
were talking before the show that it's
sort of like in 9 11 after 9 11 people
watching the tv every day and i remember
that i was a kid and and i remember
being glued to it every day and you can
see how people get whipped up to the
point where we're talking about
potentially mandating
an experimental use drug whatever you
think about it and you might think it's
the greatest thing in the world or you
might be skeptical of it mandating
at the point of a government gun
figuratively
injecting yourself with an emergency use
anything that hasn't been tested over a
long period of time and that's just
normal in 2021 america well the worrying
thing about that is just
mandating something that a doctor could
say you can't get
you like you you go to your doctor and
the doctor says i recommend no because
you have underlying medical conditions
and now what now you can't go to the
movies anymore apparently me san
francisco and new orleans and new york i
think one of the city
so yeah i mean it's been it's been uh
you know what it is though it's not
necessarily the media it is but there's
another component it is the
tribal cult-like
mentality these people have it's
authoritarianism right it's this strict
adherence to the collective
and so if the mass says so they will
just do it they will that they want it
and they have their brown shirts right
so it's like with with you know mayo
gate we're calling it they they will
they know that it's stochastic terrorism
i guess they call it right they like to
accuse the right of doing it and the
idea is that trump would come out and
say something like oh won't someone rid
me of this priest and then someone would
go do it he never directed him to do it
the idea is that if you say a bunch of
things enough people will just take
action so you don't overtly tell people
to do it in this instance it's exactly
what's happening with with the left
they'll come out and say look at this
restaurant they're liars they're evil
they they're they're far right because
they know someone will then go attack
them and i've heard so many stories like
this from conservatives where they're
like they'll get a smear piece next
thing another their phone's ringing off
the hook they're they're getting kicked
off social media they've got people
showing up at their houses this has been
going on for some time and i'll tell you
it's like it's like the rules for
radicals man they accuse the republicans
and the right and the anti-establishment
of doing exactly what they do they they
project that because it's an effective
offense then when you come back and
there's like a regular person not paying
attention you say look look what they're
doing they'll be like they said you were
doing that first
and so then they just they get away with
that tendency to believe the first thing
you hear if you hear a bunch of
information it's a lot of times it's the
first one you hear that's like codes the
mind you know the mental pathways and
then there it is also no one sees the
correction they always see the story
that gets spun out and then repeated a
trillion times and the lie told a
trillion times before you get to the
truth well what's going to win i'll i'll
give you a really good example of how
this manifests in real life
whoever calls the police first tends to
win
so if ian and i get into a fight and
then i call the police
i say tends to because it doesn't always
work that way and then i say hey i need
help this guy did this when the cops
show up and then i give a statement i'm
the one who called i have the benefit of
the doubt there's actually a con artist
exploit this well what you do is
i don't i don't want to get into the
full tricks i think we've talked about
it before but con artists will do a
trick where they will call the police on
you and then get the cops to rob you for
them
because you called the cops the cops
will typically so there's some
information gathering you need first
there's some tricks which i'm not going
to explain because i don't want him to
go and do this but yes one of a very
common hustle is to call the police on
somebody the cops will then search the
person and then give over their
possessions to you
yeah yep yep whoever calls the cops
first wins i've been i've been i've had
this i've personally experienced
situations like this
where i've been the victim of a crime
but they turned my phone off and then
called the police on me and the cops
came and arrested appeal to authority
there's an argument tactic
the cops tell me like what are we
supposed to do every time we show up
arrest both people and i'm like i called
the cops first but they turned my phone
off they took my phone they hung up on
it they cancelled it and then they
called and the cops came and arrested me
and this is exactly how elan omar has
survived thus far
with that exact tactic calling the cops
first
or just like what do you mean no i'm i'm
joking i'm saying yeah i was too much of
a straight man there to make it land
properly but i mean like there's an
element of that in the media that's a
thing right so the democrats will be
like the republicans are extremist
terrorists then antifa goes around
smashing and destroying everything and
they say well it's self-defense because
the republicans are terrorists
also i mean
leftist ideology has lent itself
historically to being
violent and at the point of a gun
imposing your belief because it there's
coercion that's necessarily built into
it if you won't go along we're gonna
have to make you go along and it's for
your own good also by the way i mean
who's ever heard of limited government
live and with people having bloody
anti-cultural revolutions has that ever
existed in the history of mankind i
don't think so i like to use some of
these analogies you know why is it that
conservatives are more likely to get
banned on social media
uh if
if if i told you that uh dave rubin
would be rallying a bunch of you know
black-clad masked far-right extremists
to twitter hq and would be smashing out
windows and stuff would you believe it
no no of course not joke it's not gonna
but if i told you that uh uh you know
antifa some left-wing organizers were
gonna be showing up with molotovs and
crowbars twitter hq would you believe it
yeah yeah of course so what do you think
jack dorsey thinks when he's got his
finger over the band button he's like i
could ban the right all day and i ain't
gonna do anything about it i'd ban one
leftist and they'll show up here with a
brick nah i don't wanna deal with that
plus they're in the bay area so they're
like we the last thing we need is all
these people storming the camp just get
rid of the conservatives but not to
mention they're in the barrier they
probably agree with antifa to a great
extent yeah
yeah there's also i feel like a little
bit of a self-loathing element to it too
like how do they reconcile their leftism
with their material success and like all
the trappings that they have there's
probably a deep-seated psychological not
that i have any expertise in this and
that maybe that'll get me banned
but but that said i do think that the
the deep-seated narcissistic
psychological part of it is probably
discounted to an extent it shouldn't be
let's talk about this story too also an
exclusive from the daily mail
you know
at least 63 people on martha's vineyard
have tested positive for covet 19 since
barack obama's maskless 60th birthday
bash the most cases on the island since
april so i don't know if all of these
people were at his party to be fair it's
just on the island but the island is not
particularly big
this is this is a great story oh i love
it obama i was like i'm scaling back my
party it's still ridiculously massive
celebrities are showing up erica badu is
posting selfies no one's wearing masks
i'll tell you you
man you could go to church and they call
it a super spreader event you actually
had you know cuomo in new york shutting
down churches this is the perfect
example i mean
i i don't understand
how
no no i'm sorry i'm sorry i get it
regular people
they'll see the news about black lives
matter protesting in the thousands and
then they're told don't worry
according to the university of colorado
it may have actually reduced the spread
of coven that's right
thousands of people standing shoulder to
shoulder oh yeah because other people
didn't want to go outside but there's
literally thousands of people outside
right now what do you talk
and people see that
i think there's people who love it
authoritarians just love
brutalizing people
and then you have regular people who are
scared of being brutalized
so when they see these stories they're
just like i better just say nothing
otherwise they'll come for me
and that's that's the problem we face
you know when it comes to that that
restaurant
uh
that was being harassed
they don't want to be politically active
and i can get that i can understand why
but this is your warning man yeah if
you're using american money you're
politically active whether you want to
be or not
that's it's uh you may not want war
about war wants to find you there's
that's where it is ideologically you're
gonna pull up a little bit yeah you can
vote around where we are right now i
think is there was a time where you
could disagree and that was it but now
it's you can't disagree you have to go
along with us it's all about
and also are your ideas so great if you
have to be coercive and impose them on
other people and you can't win with
persuasion and argumentation yet of
course words are violence but actual
violence is not violent i found that if
you you ca if you disagree and just say
i don't believe it no they get really
mad but if you offer a counterpoint
that's very intuitive often especially
in a one-on-one situation they're
receptive to it even but in the hordes
and the masses things can start to
change when you're dealing with crowds
that's
a little more difficult
this is a very creepy authoritarian time
right
barack obama announces his birthday
party basically in defiance of all cdc
regulation and they they don't bat an
eye shout out to barack obama for
exercising his first amendment right to
congregate yeah
and that's just right that's right it's
been that way the whole time though it's
rules for me not for thee and i and i do
think at a deep level it's sort of just
like thumbing their nose at the little
people and also by the way i mean
there's so many different knock-on
effects to how this has increased the
power of
what i'll you know cliche use the term
rolling class
like all the major corporations many
major corporations massively increase
their market share during this time
where mom and pop
companies got destroyed you got forced
into living remotely and then using zoom
you know a chinese product of course uh
but even leaving that aside we're in
this atomized existence where everything
is digital so now you're using
technologies of people who hate your
guts and are going to collect infinitely
more information on you as a consequence
you don't have to be a conspiracy
theorist or nut this is just what has
happened and then you know like going
out and oh i'm going to go on a vacation
wherever i'm going to have a party
mascot has read you know just before we
did put the mask mandate in i'll tell
you what it is the elites are
gathering up as much silverware as they
can before the ship the ship sinks right
so we hit the iceberg there's still some
time to get to the lifeboat they saw
that hit and they said grab as much as
you can on the way out and they're gonna
grab as much as they can because that is
them running to the lifeboat before
anyone else can and then leave and see
i think it's even more insidious because
it seems like they're moving our
industry into the these chinese
corporations that are using slave labor
and they're just like whatever they
steered us into the iceberg
they steer us into the iceberg and then
laugh and then jump on the boat and
leave the the question at the end of the
day is so i think that china is the
greatest foreign threat that we face
although i think that we are we are our
own worst enemy right now if you're a
self-loathing country if you're a
country that says forget about merit
forget about what an individual brings
to the table we're going to divide each
other on a million different bases and
be at each other's throats all the time
and basically celebrate mediocrity as
opposed to excellence and repudiate
everything that we're built on that'll
kill us well before china even gets to
us we'll do their job for them but that
said with the elites
they're now emulating china like they've
cow towed to china for decades because
they think well if we get entered this
marketplace you know massive profits for
us and china of course has played us
like a fiddle on that count
but now it's more of the emulation of
like the american social credit system
the social credit system with american
characteristics
and the blending of big tech and the
state and using that power together i
think i you know you know how i would
describe what's going on with the us
elites and china is kind of like uh you
know a vampire
and this this this guy meets the vampire
and he's like i want the power of the
vampire so i can you know
take power over all the people and
they're like we can grant you this power
but you will be subservient to us and so
these elites are like this is my in
because in china when you're in the
party you're set for life no stress
because i'll tell you this
in america you're on a treadmill and if
you're if you're walking you're standing
still
if you stop walking you'll move
backwards you've got to keep running to
get ahead not when you're in the
communist china the chinese communist
party when you're an authoritarian
regime you can finally sit back and say
i am secure my power within reason you
still have to you know
do work
but man it's hard with competition it is
so hard you know i remember when i was
when i was first starting in in this
industry i had a guy telling me when i
was 25 he was like it's really great
right now everybody loves you and
they're praising you for all the work
you're doing and by the time you're in
your 30s there's going to be some young
kid who developed some new technique and
some new tech and you're going to be
chasing after him and he's gonna be
rising and you're gonna be worried about
your business going down and i'm like oh
you know we'll see but i get the idea
right the idea that there's always
someone at your heels
so what these these these political
elites both republicans and democrats
are like how do we just finally secure
power in a way we don't have to worry
about it anymore
sell out to china too bad because what
you did was worked harder and then hired
those guys
but what what they're doing is
they they're they're tired of playing
this game right what do they do every
few years it's phone call phone call
phone call raise money raise money oh
could you imagine i i imagine there's
some like chinese communist guy and he's
like sitting there with mitch mcconnell
or whoever and he's like you know
you wouldn't have to do any of this
fundraising if you just joined the
communist party or made one and they're
in the republican or democrat they're
like really it's like that's right you
would just have the power forever
two-year term what is going on these
people are in congress for life after
five years they get pensions for life
come on except for the occasional purges
you know where a couple million get
thrown in jail every now and again
that's the only yeah that's that's the
one challenge that they have to deal
with in their system i i agree though
real quick i don't know if that pension
for life thing is true oh really yeah
okay
yeah well look it up but
i think an element of this is and it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy
there's the theory that china is just
going to overtake us and so better to
get on board with china and kowtow to
them because you think that you'll maybe
be one of the benighted party members
someday
however
of course it's those useful idiots who
are the first ones that get lined up and
shot in any revolution and so there's
that and then also on domestically let's
say the the woke ideology overtook every
single institution which it already has
to a large extent but and they really
ended up with their ideal endgame
according to their tenants who would
want to live in a country like that the
elites they might be behind 50-foot
walls with private security guards
around them and stuff but like you're
they can't send their kids to school
like how how is your life going to
function so i think it's it's
short-sighted that authoritarian
instinct ultimately is going to end up
in a very
i mean a disastrous situation for them
and their families remember john cena
speaking mandarin in that apology it's
pathetic it says everything
these people have already been lining up
at the door for china for the money
you've got the nba you have the video
game companies anybody who's like i'm
sorry man i i have a rather negative
view of where this country's headed
because it's been decades now where
we've been as ian pointed out sending
away our manufacturing base our our
industry the core of this country being
extracted and sent off overseas not just
not just to china but other countries as
well and even mexico that's been
happening for so long
trump tries turning that around to a
great deal and he succeeded in many ways
and
they weaponize the media institutions to
crush it you notice the greatest assault
the greatest attacks on trump usually
came from the national security and
foreign policy and intelligence
apparatus and those were the areas where
he was upsetting the apple card probably
to a greater degree than anywhere else
they really they didn't yes they hated a
million different things about him they
hated him aesthetically i think he
created on them oh yeah but they also
really hated the fact that he threatened
their power and privilege because he
tried to undo
the establishment progressive wilsonian
however you want to describe it national
security and foreign policy he was a
threat they perceived him as a threat to
their power and privilege the people who
are voting in
more more of the uniparty and i don't
just mean democrats it's like mcconnell
saying we need more troops in
afghanistan there are a lot of populist
right individuals now who are running
for uh that we're gonna see in the
midterms which is which is really uh
cause for optimism but the unit party
itself like look the neocons fled to the
democratic party when trump got elected
and then all of a sudden the democrats
became that
tower or whatever i just think it's
hilarious the idea that
you have people voting in their own
destruction
while thinking they're not thinking
they're the ones who aren't not paying
attention and it's funny when you look
at the polls independent voters and
republican voters
think the economy is doing bad well i
think by most metrics they would be
correct the democrats think the economy
is doing fairly good which by most
metrics makes literally no sense unless
you're in a cult
isn't that funny but what the media is
able to do is they're able to point to
the fringes of trump supporters to claim
that represents all of you know everyone
anyone who's anti-democrat or
anti-establishment
is that one small fringe of of the the
die-hard trump supporter you know
and then you get these people that are
effectively voting in their own
serfdom
that's what i think i think it's kind of
funny like in in the end i don't think
i i don't think necessarily let me put
it this way i'm not worried
i'm not worried about myself i think if
the country falls apart if we end up
with some you know internal conflict
civil conflict or something like that it
would suck really bad i think china
would then easily just sweep across
crush our allies take over everything
and become the dominant empire and that
seems to be like what will happen
considering what's happening in this
country and i know that i will survive
i'm confident in my abilities i've been
homeless before i'm not all that worried
i think it'll be an adventure but i'll
tell you these people in the cities are
going to cry a deep cry they will sob
they sob they've never sobbed before if
they if they only could see the future
as to what they're going to bring to
their their their countrymen to the men
and women of this nation
man
i'm not going to pretend like a voting
republican gets you out of the problem
either it's like the republicans of the
speed bump the democrats are the ones
setting fire to the the building in the
first place so i don't know what you do
but i think when when all the bricks
come tumbling down
i don't know life will suck for the most
part
mostly conservatives will probably be
fine
urban liberals will probably be in very
serious i don't know if that's even safe
to say because if we're really headed
towards what you're talking about
oh okay if you play fallout the theme is
2060 there's a war between america and
china i'm worried about that a nuclear
war then i'm worried about an artificial
intelligence war a robot war where they
have drones flying around patrolling the
skies shooting at anything that moves
people are running from building to
building all over earth
that's very and then no one no human at
that point will be safe that's very
likely if we don't get our
stuff together right now as a race
that is very possible as a future option
we're going that route man
many routes at once but that is one of
them the the drones in the sky
ai seeking out you know skynet and stuff
maybe not too far-fetched considering
what they already have with the you know
the reaper drones and stuff like that
but i i so maybe i don't think they have
enough of them for a country as large as
the united states they can make drones
that can make drones i i if when ai is
working 24 7
and doesn't get tired someone has to
bring this otherwise to them it's not
it's not that simple i don't know maybe
maybe in 30 to 50 years we might have
the infrastructure for for look
someone's got to mine the materials but
it ten years go by and then it's only 20
to 40 years and then
another 10 years go by what have we done
you know when we can solve the mining
problem of how we got humans and sulfur
mines and things like that then there'll
be a big change for the time being it's
a human task
and then you're probably mining
asteroids and then you might have a
self-driving truck delivering the
materials to the a but i don't think
that's that's the issue i think that's
something to be concerned about no i
think the bigger issue is the economy
just crumbles that's the short-term
problem yeah and i'm saying if the
economy if the economy crumbled right
now and you'd go to the store and a
gallon of milk was 100 bucks and there
was like three available and people are
fighting over a can of beans in the
parking lot
i think i'd be fine i wouldn't be happy
i wouldn't be comfortable and i wouldn't
pretend like i'm going to be sitting
atop a throne or anything no it would be
a constant battle for survival when
there's like limited goods and no fuel
but the people in the cities and the
suburbs
they ain't going to be having a good
government they're going to be in the
parking lot fighting for beans with
agnes i keep hearing that china is a
paper tiger have you you've been
studying this a lot have you found stuff
like this
and what i mean by that is that they're
putting on a big show of force but that
they're actually very weak and and
vulnerable right now as a government
so i mean you know it'd be cliche to say
act weak when you're strong and act
strong when you're weak and then their
strategy was hide your strength by your
time that was really sort of the
overarching vision of deng xiaoping and
then sort of build up and then you can
start acting very assertively and
aggressively
i think that i don't think that they're
50 feet
tall
and they might think that we're 50 feet
tall which should mean that we really
have to up our game because they're a
lot more serious than we are i mean when
we have our generals talking about
you know general milly talking about i
really want to understand white ridge
what kind of message he means yeah i
mean of course right yeah
what kind of message does that send to a
people that has no qualms about killing
its own citizens crushing hong kongers
threatening taiwan threatening
chinese nationals abroad in every single
country
they don't i don't think they perceive
us to be serious so that's dangerous
potentially that they have that
perception that we're not serious but i
think also it's reality in a lot of
respects now are they a paper tiger like
if you're looking at how many you know
nuclear warheads do they have and you go
through all those conventional weapons i
don't think that ultimately the conflict
i think we're in the conflict with china
that'd be the first thing i'd say
they've been in at war in one way or
another with us for decades would be my
art probably since the late 1800s since
the opium war well you could go back and
they would and that and that would be a
grievance you know they have kind of
their historical narrative of the west
putting them down and continuing now
they're going to rise up and we're going
to be you know returned to our
being the center of the world the middle
kingdom
you know are there economic numbers real
i would put zero stock in you know we
grew at 35 percent last year yeah i
wouldn't put any stock in that
whatsoever but where they clearly have
significant power
is in the realm of
influence over everyone else the fact
that you can bring an american to his
knees to kowtow over taiwan i think
tells you all you need to know do they
do that when it comes to america did
they do the reverse and also they
understand how foolish we've been i mean
the business community just put out a
letter recently i wrote about this at
newsweek talk saying to the biden
administration you really need to go
back to the table on more
negotiating with china because we need
to increase trade and economic
engagement with china and it starts and
you got to remove those tariffs as soon
as possible also we understand you know
there are all sorts of issues with
china's predatory economic practices but
we really need to get back to the table
and it and by the way it's america first
too it's good for the american workers
there's gonna be an anti-inflationary
policy you'll watch you'll see
on what basis whatsoever would any
serious people say you know what i've
seen the way china's acted just over the
last 18 months let's definitely go and
engage more with them when that has been
the entire strategy it's been a bear hug
strategy it's let's invite the west in
they'll give us capital we'll steal
their technology they'll get nothing out
of us ultimately we'll have all of the
major industries dominated monopolized
so that during something like a pandemic
for example we can threaten to withhold
essential medicines from you so
control 5g infrastructure the funny
thing about this is
we have the the
xinjiang province the uyghur muslims and
that i can't even make a joke about them
considering it when it comes to these
these trade deals like i'd like to make
a joke where there's like some corporate
executives being like gentlemen
we've just got this report that they're
torturing they're forced there's forced
abortions these people are being you
know
is ethnic cleansing is horrible we have
to consider our business practices with
this country i can't even make that joke
because when they're sitting in the
office some guy goes oh did you hear
they got a concentration camp does it
affect our bottom line not at all
praise the lord it's like all right
great what's our numbers this time
around oh anyway moving on they don't
care at all about that stuff collateral
damage so so you have to understand it's
outside of the fact that they're ripping
us off stealing our ip they're
threatening us in terms of the south the
south china sea they're threatening
taiwan one of our one of our allies and
our chips computer chips that we need
and they're also just morally repugnant
within their own country that's what i'm
wondering and we're just like america is
just like yeah but you know it's the
power you brought up the word kowtow a
few times it basically means i'm looking
at the definition here act excessively
absurd service manner but it comes from
a chinese idea that you would go to the
emperor bow on your knees put your
forehead on the ground and beg
submission from the empire and the
emperor
and forward foreign leaders would go to
china and they would bow and put to the
emperor and like and then you'd have the
blessing of china and they would send
you money and they would send you troops
and they would send you architects and
things to come and work with you and is
it still like that is there still a
chinese emperor i don't even know right
now is it a xi jinping xi jinping is is
the emperor so they dispelled with the
empire now it's just a communist party
but he's still acting as if the child
he's the child of heaven is this it's a
it's it's a communist party but with
confucian
characteristics he's i mean look i don't
think that xi jinping is like this great
philosopher king dictator but but he is
sort of blended propagandistically
the traditional chinese cultural ethosis
with communism and so he is the next
thing to mao i mean he's number two
after mao essentially there now of
course
like michael bloomberg talking about
like well he has domestic constituencies
too even though it's not a democracy i
mean he has he has other members of the
communist party who would probably like
to have his seat but like i said he also
engaged in a purge soon after he entered
which he caught an anti-corruption purge
which is basically taking out two to
three million members of the party
probably who he felt you know were a
threat to him i mean jailing not always
murdering them but you know that's just
another day
you know you got to kill the king to be
the king yeah who's the what's the real
power of china they put mao or they put
a what's his name xi jinping in the
front but i imagine it's like an
oligarchical
dark state like a quiet people behind
the scenes that no one knows who they
are that are running things
he everyone is answerable to him
obviously like you know first of all
it's also worth noting their military
the poa is the chinese communist party
is military it's not china's military
it's a distinction worth making it's the
party's military arm and she has taken
substantial control over that military
in his time
running the country
look it's very clear that the private
companies there's been a massive regulat
regulatory crackdown i mean you got to
put all these things in air quotes there
but massive regulatory crackdown jack ma
you know was essentially disappeared for
months and then reemerged they scuttled
the ipo that his company was going to go
through his value went from 900 billion
to 450 billion at least and it's
probably still dropping they're just
selling off parts of his companies to
party members and who else i don't know
in july
of 2021
u.s listed chinese companies lost 400
billion dollars in market value under
this regulatory crackdown you talk about
oligarchical powers i mean the people
running these companies who are all
party members obviously
if those are your oligarchs they're
being cut down to size in real time so
like their vulnerabilities i mean their
vulnerabilities which will never know
and do i trust our intelligence to see
them i don't know but that said yeah
look in a system like that with a
one-man dictator he obviously has to
answer to other people because they're
all at his throat all the time right not
his not his citizen not the citizen and
like who owns the party owns the land so
who owns the party
the goblin king whoever is that's what
they say that's what they make us think
but i don't think so i think mao is too
dangerous so they they make sure that
it's like a puppet now i i am not
convinced even our intelligence agencies
are uh genuinely concerned with
preserving and protecting this nation i
think when you look at afghanistan and
and the afghan papers what you really
have is
a disaster where everyone's just like i
don't want to get in trouble how much
can i extract from the system before it
all falls on my head
i think that of like every institution
i'm looking at and unfortunately
it's it's almost like with trump there
was this
kind of sporadic
bombastic
attempt at some kind of cobbling
together
a return to
i guess some kind of nationalism like
we're gonna have borders we're gonna
have uh we're gonna put more controls on
immigration we're gonna have the
industries come back we're gonna try and
help the american people get jobs and
better their lives and that was a threat
to those who are trying to extract the
last little bit from the system so they
also collectively screen it's it's it's
um what's the right word for it
basically the confidence in this country
has been lost for a long time to the
point where even our elites have no
confidence in it and they're selling out
to china among other among other
sellouts you saw it perfectly
personified in the conversation between
the secretary of state blinken and the
national security advisor and they're
meeting with their chinese counterparts
in anchorage and by the way what did
china do to deserve to have that high
level meeting i mean in the first place
if you're really serious about them and
you ascribe
primary culpability in the coronavirus
pandemic at the very least spreading
worldwide well of course they protected
themselves
why would you ever meet with them over
anything i mean they should be viewed as
they're the most culpable country in
this and trump said you know 10 trillion
dollars that's probably an
underestimation of what they should pay
in terms of recompense but that meeting
the chinese communist party dignitaries
basically said oh you're going to attack
us over human rights well look at you
you're a systemically racist country and
your history is awful et cetera and and
lincoln and and uh sullivan the national
security adviser sort of like well we
accept your premise but
you have no moral comp you have no
confidence you have no vision basically
you're saying yeah we agree our
adversaries propaganda that the left has
put out about america for decades is
true they've drank the coolies right so
who's going to defend the country if you
say that at court is a rotten deplorable
irredeemable country when when you have
a substantial amount of people in this
country saying that it's a self-fulfill
it is a self-fulfilling prophecy and
when you have this critical race applied
principles now manifesting in our
schools manifesting in our media the rot
has got to the foundation and
how long can the building stand
racial marxism that that which is you
know it's really just a rhetorical game
critical race theory in a lot of ways
it's it's like putting a a just and
virtuous veneer on your regressive
ideology of saying well we're fighting
for the good people and you're the bad
people et cetera but i i totally agree
it's the rod and the corruption is
incredibly deep on the other hand maybe
more people are awake to the fact that
this is a game that's being played than
ever before it's never been exposed i
think in such crystal clear fashion how
corrupted all the institutions are that
the blindfold has been removed i think
for a lot of people but the question is
how many people and how far gone are we
i am
i'm optimistic and pessimistic in a
certain way i think that when it comes
to the rise of china
you're familiar with the city's trap we
we've we discussed quite a bit on this
show like so i think this is real fear
among elites that war is inevitable and
so if they
hobble america it will prevent that war
from happening so it's take the the
crowbar to the knee to america and then
we avoid the war because america can't
stand up against china so i'm
pessimistic in that sense i'm optimistic
in the sense that i think
i'm starting to feel more and more like
what power canceled culture and all
these things had has been weakened to a
certain degree seeing these parents
start rising up one parent actually
punched a teacher like beat them pretty
bad that's an awful story man but you
see the parents are getting so fed up
with what's happening in these schools
they're snapping and we had bannon on
the show and he said come august 15th
when these parents figure out what
they're doing to their kids they're
going to go nuts seeing these parents
you know come up i'm kind of like
aside from the i don't like the violence
but the parents going out and protesting
and saying no to these schools the the
the push for homeschooling or for pods
school pods where like local like the
kids in the neighborhood all go with one
tutor or whatever get taught
that's optimistic because maybe maybe we
get hobbled and maybe china does make a
big move and becomes the the the economy
of the world the super economy uh in
2028 or whatever there's real risks that
we're going to lose out if china falls
to to mainland china of taiwan falls to
china
and uh what that means for the united
states in terms of our resources our
access but i do think there's always a
light there's always a you know an open
window and a door's shut that's we're
going to start seeing people start
waking up to this the hard times will
create strong men and then there there
will be some kind of resurgence that'd
be if taiwan were to fall to china that
would actually be if china were to fall
to the ccp because taiwan is china
exactly the republic of china's china
the ccp's co-opted and west taiwan is
you know being has been taken over by
communists so that's true yeah so if the
republic of china can take back west
taiwan it was funny i posted that meme
ever see it west taiwan and all of
mainland china says west island and boy
do people get mad
they don't like that one called the
chinese bots well let's talk about
what's happening here in the u.s and why
i think you know look man things aren't
aren't looking too pretty
we got the story from timcast.com biden
administration has discussed mandating
vaccines for interstate travel
the administration is reportedly looking
for ways to make life more uncomfortable
for those who do not comply the ap
reports quote well more severe measures
such as mandating vaccines for
interstate travel or changing how the
federal government reimburses treatment
for those who are unvaccinated and
become ill with covered have been
discussed the administration worried
they would be too polarizing at this
time an administration official said the
interstate travel vaccination
requirement was not under consideration
at the moment that's not to say they
won't be implemented in the future as
public opinion continues to shift toward
requiring vaccinations as a means to
restore normalcy the report adds
i think this is a big ask you know
you're familiar with the big ask
ask someone for a hundred dollars they
recoil and say okay fine how about 50
and then they say oh that sounds better
even though it's still 50 bucks this is
them being like well we want to mandate
interstate you know passports so foreign
goes whoa that's crazy and they say well
hold on if you just get vaccinated we
won't have to worry about it so i think
it's a big ask they're trying to show
you something completely unreasonable
but that says to me that if that's the
direction they have to go if that's what
they have to say to get to that point
we're dangerously close to it as it is
if for some reason
public opinion just shifts in its
direction like they claim which i don't
think so because parents are freaking
out you know what would happen if they
implemented mandate vaccine mandates for
interstate travel all the people that
can't get them for medical purposes
couldn't travel it would be insane
completely disrupt the social structure
of the country the country would just
fall apart instantly because you've got
in the area where right now we're in a
tri-state so we gotta cross the state
borders to go to the store if i want
milk we gotta we gotta go to a different
state so what happens when they're like
you gotta stop at a checkpoint the
bridge would be cluttered
how are they gonna they're gonna
checkpoint people and ask for their
their their app or something
otherwise there's no real mandate if i
just spend a trillion dollars to pay
policemen to sit at every border
crossing this is interesting during the
uh the lockdowns there it was like you
were told you couldn't travel outside
the states
like you know ian you mentioned before
you said no lockdowns didn't happen
lockdown's happened okay so where we are
they the states had rules that you could
not leave the state and if you did you
had to quarantine i think i remember so
you could get in your car and drive
there were some exemptions for people
who live within a certain amount of uh
certain miles of a border of a state so
where we are it was like we were
exempted we were allowed to
but there was someone i was talking to
up in massachusetts we wanted to have
them come on the show and they said the
problem was
when they drive to the store to get milk
they have to drive across the border and
then they could get stopped or according
to the law they have to quarantine so
they were concerned like if i leave and
come back they're gonna they're gonna
force me to lock down i can't leave the
house for two weeks i can't even go to
the store so they were forced to go
further out in their own state
these things have happened
they didn't have people at the borders
that some places did have the same i
think texas had this i think new mexico
had this in some areas and i think
connecticut had this in some areas but
if they went across the board with this
you might as well just consider each
state its own country at that point
like like the eu or something even
though they don't have checkpoints
between the eu countries in the schengen
zone you know
global warming used as a pretext for
de-industrialize your economy and you
know go back to
go back to the land i guess
similar thing here public health as a
justification for whatever you want to
do in terms of imposing authority public
health and national security grounds are
going to be the grounds that are used
intentionally or not to eviscerate
everything i mean we've seen with
coronavirus
obviously the censorship associated with
it and that's government by proxy via
big tech
abrogating the first amendment you see
it with locking everyone down but
letting social justice warriors out into
the streets selectively allowing people
to enjoy their rights i mean locking
down places
when look in a free society there are
risks people weigh the risks and then
they act accordingly if we're a free
society but clearly we're increasingly
not free society can can i violate
godwin's law for a second yeah you know
that the nazis claimed jewish people
carried typhus
and that was one of the reasons they
needed to to mark people and they were
all in yeah
look public health is a really easy and
easy way for authoritarians to get in
because people are scared of disease you
don't want to kill people right right
that's the whole thing i always say this
did you you know when when you watch
movies like or when you read books like
1984 when you watch these nightmare
dystopia movies when you're watching for
vendetta did you think that when
authoritarianism came to your front door
there would be no excuse
like when you see these movies where
it's like there's the resistance and
they just live in this nightmare
dystopia do you think that one day the
the chancellor stood up and said oh by
the way i'm not a dictator and we're a
fascist you know did you think it would
be obvious when they came because it
wasn't and it never will be no it is
when they really come it is obvious no
they're sub they're subterfugal man you
never see it coming that's the point you
gotta be aware and stay back from
you you're incorrect we are watching it
happen you saw it but no no no no no no
i didn't realize it when covid came out
right that it was gonna be like this
right now they are saying they're
they're discussing
passports for interstate travel it is in
your face but they have an excuse for it
so people gladly drop to their knees and
say please state keep me safe and take
my freedoms from me because apparently
these people never read anything from
benjamin franklin
those who would give up their freedom or
was it essential liberties for a little
bit of security deserve neither and will
lose both i really agree with your point
on your perspective on this statement uh
about what they could be doing if they
want i thought the first thing i thought
was that it's a flex it feels like a big
military flex like you know we could
shut everything down all the borders but
we're not gonna and it's like they're
holding that over over our heads if they
want to but it is overton window
shifting yes it makes what what is
perceived as reasonable
six months from now what's crazy
today and they've done that in so i mean
two weeks to slow the curve
yeah and and like we've never locked
down our country ever before
certainly if not for those periods of
time for any reason whatsoever
the the power grabs have been to your
point
so in your face
and the the and look you also just said
as public opinion shifts but there's
something called a constitution i mean
it clearly isn't worth the paper it's
printed out anymore it shouldn't be if
public opinion shifts it's what's the
law what's not you know obviously they
don't they don't care i don't think like
the cdc eviction
thing you know where he's basically like
yeah i know it's not constitutional
whatever but it's you know it's tough
times i mean then you don't then your
law is worth nothing but you're not a
free western country anymore i think the
law is mostly worth nothing i think
culture is everything there are certain
laws on the books we've talked about in
the show like uh you know there's this
old book you can you can get where it's
like laws that would shock you or
whatever and it's just like this little
trivia thing and it's like you can't put
an apple pie on the windowsill on
thursdays you can't you can't use your
your garden hose at 3 p.m on a monday
afternoon and a full moon and you're
like what are these weird laws that
never get enforced but they're all in
the books
because culturally we say oh that's
absurd no one would do that so even
though the law clearly states you can't
we never got rid of it and there's a ton
of really crazy laws still in the books
people super chat them uh super chat to
us all the time so what happens is we
got a constitution
but if they can they can just keep
pushing to the point where we're clearly
beyond the constitution
what happens now is they say we're not
violating your rights by shutting down
your speech on a private platform even
if that private platform is the only
place political disc is the dominant
place political discourse happens we are
not violating your right to bear arms by
telling you you can't own specific
firearms you can always have a single
loaded you know bolt action or whatever
they're saying we're not violating your
third amendment rights by mandating you
house people because only some of those
people are soldiers we're not violating
your fourth amendment rights with search
insurgency because i smelled pot so
eventually they keep saying things like
this and then once these once these
amendments are are just washed over
they'll say the constitution we haven't
used that in years
no one takes that seriously wow that's
right and even now that
you know the left and and you know maybe
republicans too but primarily left they
will appeal to the constitution when
they think it serves them and when it
doesn't they'll say well it's an old
document and it's outdated and it wasn't
made for the times and it's it's a
living document and also china analog
here china they have rule by law as
opposed to rule of law and that is
increasingly where we are it is rule by
law and also that law is selectively
applied and if you apply the law to one
person one way and another person
another way then you have no rule of law
double standard justice means no justice
so what's the difference of rule by law
and of law
well rule by law is essentially whatever
the state says goes and narco tyranny
the rule of laws the state has to adhere
to the documents of law and the p and at
core the sovereign people at the end of
the day rule by law is oh we're going to
put a national security law on the books
which says and they have really have
this intelligence and national security
laws
you know if your company is dealing in
sensitive information or if the state
needs it basically you have to turn over
everything to us and serve us as an
apparatus and also like the law doesn't
mean
whatever's on paper doesn't actually
mean anything at the end of the day it's
what the ruler says it is that's it's an
arc of tierney right so here in the u.s
you can see like january 6 is a great
example they will
i mean these people are in solitary
they're getting months in prison for
many of them are literally just charged
with trespassing some of these people
there's one video of like an old lady
walking through a door where a cop holds
it open for her and she's getting
charged like come on man if i go to a
building and cops like right this way
sir i'd be like cool and they're like
you trespass
that's like the literal example of
entrapment he entrapped that's true
that's a good point because entrapment
requires some coercion on the part of
the government if the government comes
to you and said well actually maybe not
maybe not they say come right in sir and
you walk in and then they're
arrested it's not true it's not
entertainment they have to they have to
coerce you in some way
they have to say come on in that's
coercement no it's not uh did he just
did you just step aside and hold if he
opened a door for someone entrapment
would be ian if you don't do this i'll
punch you in the face oh so at threats
he always threatened into doing so so
happy to say
you know we'll we'll take your child
away from you or you'll you know we'll
come for you we'll do x to you that's
coercion so it's not entrapment but it
clearly shows it wasn't trespassing
right so you have right now the
government willing to enforce anything
to bolster its power meanwhile antifa
can go and burn down your business with
impunity because that's an arco tyranny
they they
only it's it's look man
ian you made a fallout reference already
it feels to me are you familiar with the
fallout franchise yep so it feels to me
like the government at this point is
just the enclave
and they leave every everything else is
the wastes and then when they want to
take and do whatever they want they just
go and do it as if we don't exist so
crazy they don't serve the people it is
just institutions of power that serves
itself yeah we there's so much um hope
and with technology lately like you can
withdraw the carbon dioxide from the air
and
deposit it on a palladium make graphene
with it you can
you know iron fertilize the oceans to
regrow the plankton to re-bloom the fish
population you can shatter coral and it
all grows at the same time to regrow
coral reefs you can seed bomb deserts to
plant trees like hundreds of millions of
trees per day there's
so much it's so easy if we
know what to do and work together we do
you know my favorite terraforming method
is you mentioned a lot of really great
things that we can do to help heal the
plant my favorite is building a casino
in the desert
yeah good point cause that's what vegas
did and now there's clouds that's
amazing they got clouds there now and
they got grass they bring it all in they
import water and food and then people
fly there and then they they drain
bathrooms which puts more water into the
system and the water evaporates yeah
we're mechanically
like terraforming las vegas it's really
interesting but let's talk about
larry
because uh i saw this meme first we have
this story from timcast.com two visitors
arrested in hawaii for using forged
vaccine cards governor david ige as i
pronounce it made the announcement on
twitter here are these two men
apparently they had fake vaccine cards
because you got a quarantine for two
weeks
here's fascinating there's a meme on
reddit
where like someone on twitter said
morons out here be spending 400 bucks on
fake vaccine cards when the vaccine is
free and then all the comments are like
that's how stupid these people are
they're so dumb you can just get a free
vaccine card with your vaccine why spend
400 bucks i'm like man these people are
really that stupid they don't understand
why they forget vaccine cards it's
because they don't want to get the
vaccine oh
have you considered this
it's the weirdest thing to me uh i think
the big problem with uh
we're i think we're definitely see a lot
more of this we've got we got this other
story here this is this is uh really
interesting from mashable black market
for fake vaccine cards is thriving on
telegram oh yeah channels with hundreds
of thousands of subscribers would be
happy to sell you a counterfeit for 100
bucks now my understanding it is illegal
if the cdc logo is on it
that's what that's what i heard so there
was a report that came out said do not
buy these they're illegal if you have
them
if they're using federal government
logos masquerading as an official
document
but i guess and i'm if it's just a
postcard that says vaccine
must be okay i guess the vaccine card
that i had when i when i traveled to
venezuela was just a yellow card and it
said vaccine schedule and then the
doctor signed the vaccines on it and
then he wrote vaccines on it then signed
it and there was no official anything on
it it was just a yellow postcard i had
to show that in venezuela when i went to
the country they were like because you
have to have certain you know vaccines
to enter the country so in this regard i
don't know how you how you enforce these
things you know these lockdowns that's
why i think a lot of it might be saber
rattling or threats of intimidation or
big asks
also could they even competently execute
it let's say they did impose the system
i mean i guess maybe you could say that
bureaucratic incompetence might be the
saving grace as we head down this path
of
social credit system with american
characteristics and you have to show
your papers to function in life and also
the officials act like you know they're
being so beneficent like if you just get
this card you can live like an american
once again
how how disturb that was basically beau
de blasio new york's um god forsaken
mayor on the way out that was
essentially what he said almost verbatim
you can go about your daily lives and do
what you did before so long as you have
this card you know you know what i i'm
calling it
the lockdowns are back
they are locking down cities
they're legit
unless you get a vaccine
to you in new york and san francisco and
new orleans the city is entirely locked
down
you can't go into any restaurant or gym
or bar or venue or theater or or
whatever
unless you have the vaccine that's a
lockdown maybe it's gated the cities are
gated they're locked down well and this
also gets to the delicious challenge for
the so-called anti-racist the racist
anti-racist to
define equity in terms of outcomes
and and of course disparate treatment as
a reflection of racism in a case like
this if you have
ethnic minorities in this country who
disproportionately
do not get vaccinated and their lives
are made miserable as a consequence of
these mandates what are the what is the
answer what does ibromex kennedy say
about this and james lindsey tweeted
about this um everyone's got to ask the
critical race theorists yeah if the the
black population or the least likely to
be vaccinated then who's getting
excluded from public accommodations
right now overwhelmingly the blacks use
their own racism against them i mean
it's literally a racist policy to
implement i actually think it's a good
reason not to have vaccine mandates
because it creates racial disparity
i oppose that stuff i'm in favor of the
civil rights protesters and
that movement i think public
accommodations should uh provide
accommodation to the public
i've always maintained that position
i've had a lot of conservatives who like
you know i've always argued i think if
you have a bakery and someone comes in i
actually said i think the baker should
write the message but i understand the
first amendment argument he actually won
on that one so maybe i'm wrong i'm just
like if it were me i'd be like i don't
consider it my speech well let me slow
down a bit the the bakery thing everyone
knows about in colorado
he was willing to serve uh uh serve the
gay couple who wanted the cake he just
didn't want to write specifically what
they wanted to write because he didn't
want to be compelled to speak to speech
i understand that my thing is like
in general so i think i actually agree
with conservatives in that regard what
i'm saying is if somebody of different
racial background or identity or
national origin comes to your business i
think you should have to serve them
because we're all taxpayers here man
you're occupying space they're coming in
you should be able to throw someone out
for some you know bs reasons that being
said if they start screaming or yelling
or they smell bad or whatever you've got
civil disruption yeah you're allowed to
kick them out and things like that you
know what i mean no you're not though no
you've got to let them squat in your
house
that's right you have no i mean the
criminals if you're an illegal alien you
have more rights than a u.s citizen in
some respects it's amazing isn't it
they're talking about these vaccine
mandates for interstate travel meanwhile
the border it's just did you see ivory
hecker's uh she went down to the border
and got video footage of
buses coming back and forth and she
talked to an incoming migrant i think he
was incoming migrant that had a piece of
paper on the back said i do not speak
english
uh where should i go to catch my flight
and on the back was his flight itinerary
taking him like into the middle of the
united states yep is that confirmed that
he was like in from across the border yo
joe biden was smuggling children into
others two days ago what right yeah
ivory by the way that was an exclusive
reporter
yeah tim cass picked that up man yeah
she went down to the border and she was
like what's going on and she got you
know footage of all this stuff
i haven't personally confirmed that he
was from across the border but it's i
think that's
there's more than one
they get these manila folders with their
itineraries and they're like where do i
go now
and uh so what are we at we're at 1.2
million i think yep 1.2 on the books on
the books right yeah and also by the way
this i mean there's so many different
things that can be said about this but
this is the super spreader event it is a
rolling perpetual super spreader event
the open border number one forget about
the national security implications this
which aren't even talked about in
context of an open border
and then you know we just had the census
results that everyone wanted to talk
about and one of the things that's not
talked about and i hammered this home i
don't know why this arcane point stuck
with me but in relation to the open
borders and i wrote about this a bunch
over the last couple years when the
trump administration essentially made
wanted to make respondents to the census
say are you a citizen or not why is that
important
non-citizens including illegal aliens
get counted in the census
consequently
the numbers ascribed to them are used
for apportioning congressional seats and
also allocating hundreds of billions of
dollars down to intellectual localities
so that very few people bring this point
no one talks about this this is foreign
interference and all right right we i
can't remember who we had on recently
and i brought this point up because i
think california in the past this is
according to a heritage foundation
california gained one extra electoral
vote in in in federal election in the
presidential election because of their
illegal immigration population
so you know tucker carlson comes out and
he says this they're bringing in people
because they want to give them
citizenship so they'll vote for
democrats i'm like no they want to bring
them in because they get counted on the
census in the next 10 years then they
get more congressional seats to their to
their states and more power to elect the
president it is subverting our electoral
process and giving our taxpayer dollars
to people who did not come to this
country through the legal process it's
just it's an extraction on the system
it's basically deluding
it's disenfranchising american citizens
at the highest level it's foreign
interference in our elections and you
don't even need a mass amnesty then to
change the system yeah people don't
realize that like when tucker said this
i'm like we don't choose the president
by a popular vote
they don't need to vote they just need
to give congressional seats to
california so that california can
continue to influence the federal
government which means california's laws
will affect wyoming if california allows
people what are they doing like free
health care for people under 26 illegal
immigrants if they're going to keep
sanctuary state you can't deport our
people
you know what the problem is i blame the
republicans
i completely blame the republicans look
if they're if there's a string of
criminals in your neighborhood smashing
out of the windows
you're like okay the criminals are bad
what do we do to stop them i know we'll
all pool our money together and then
hire a security firm to deal with it and
then you see the security firm being
like well we can't arrest them because
you know it's like well i blame you
you're the per you're look obviously
first and foremost the democrats are the
bad guys in this regard they're they're
effectively manipulating our electoral
system by doing this
where where is where's anybody to stop
him
the republicans pretend to be on your
side there's a handful you know the the
the rand paul's thomas massey um i think
holly's pretty good ted cruz seemed is
okay but you know i really do think rand
paul tends to be the one guy who's
actually filibustering and trying to
stop a lot of stuff and you get lindsey
graham and mitch mcconnell and what are
they doing tucker carlson called lindsey
graham a leftist like he's just a
straight-up leftist and mcconnell's like
we had more tropes in afghanistan i'm
like these people don't care about you
they pretend to be the the the the
resistance the what the democrats are
doing but they're really just the
gatekeepers to stop you from getting
anywhere near them
and in effect controlled opposition
right at the end of the day and i mean
it's a uniparty it's a uni party
yeah and and
part of it it probably is like the
superficial you know got to go to the
red cocktail parties and you you don't
want to be attacked in the washington
post in the new york times
but the disparity the chasm between our
purported representatives and us just
goes grows greater and greater and it's
more transparent than it's ever been so
the question is are the bums gonna get
voted out of office ever and usually
they don't get primary because
incumbency is a really powerful thing
did you hear about the trans anarchist
satanist who won uh the primary for
sheriff up in new hampshire
i did not hear about it as a republican
because the republican voters went in
and said republican republican
republican republican republican and
walked out and then this person ran as a
republican and ended up winning and then
said it's your fault if you have a
problem with it maybe you should read
the names of the people and do some
research or just not vote for them if
you could get a job and if you did your
best and made the most epic thing and
then lost it your job or you could do a
mediocre thing and keep your job
which would you choose okay what's the
point of the job is it do the best work
or is it to continue to work it to
continue to work there and these these
people in office seem like what they're
doing is playing a pers uh a public
perception game they want propaganda to
make them look good because their whole
point is to stay there to get voted in
with another popularity contest there
are puppets dancing before as opposed to
doing the best job they can and then
damn be the consequences but this is
because there's no term limits at least
that's one one incentive for it maybe
maybe
we've had it back and forth on the
argument turn limits because uh one of
the arguments first and foremost is if
people want to vote for someone they
should be able to vote for him the other
thing is what happens when you get like
a ron paul who's in congress for what do
you have like 11 terms or something he's
in there for a really long time and that
dude was awesome i think that the
problems that come from it outweigh the
benefits you're right and ron paul i
think did repeatedly vote for term
limits so
yep
or would you just have new blood that
comes in every time and gets corrupted
and it's just it's it's really no
different at the end of the day or a
cabal that just recruits the new young
person to come in and then you have
someone without the experience and the
connections to actually have any
meaningful resistance see what you
really need at the end of the day is a
system where
those who get elected do not enrich
themselves as a consequence of their
office or really gain power which
requires a small government system in
the first place that's the river like
who would be attracted to washington if
there was no power in washington well
people actually want to do a good job
like you're saying so how do you
disincentivize essentially the power
grabbing i figured it out jokingly
before i called some i said martism and
the idea is that
uh once you're elected to office you
know we we take all of congress and we
put them on a rocket ship that goes to
mars
that's it i like the way this is
orientation but but now i think about it
and once they're on mars then they
actually from mars
can global government farm universal
government well just for america i'm
saying our our federal congress will be
blasted off to mars to a space colony
where they'll live out their days and
they can vote on policy positions for
which they will never experience they
have no incentive to cause harm to
people they have no incentive to enrich
themselves it's literally just what can
we do to make america better because if
america does good we send you supplies
and that's it
so uh
you know more seriously though
how do we make it so that getting out in
an office is not something you not not
something you want
for yourself
but something you want for others i
don't know how you solve for that uh uh
andrew yang's plan was like pay four
million dollars but then ban you from
working in like the private sector or
something like that you say service
service gives citizenship and that could
be the service that everyone has to face
that at some point in their life denmark
ben franklin wanted no pay for those
people and at this point that we can do
it on the internet we kind of don't need
to get paid no pay but then you'd only
have the rich oligarchs running for
office you know like that i'm sure that
would be the argument but what if we
didn't have those offices anymore this
is something that's been on my mind a
lot that if instead of voting for
representatives that would then write
laws for you that anyone could write the
laws and pass them into the senate like
any any american citizen and also if
they were going to make votes there's
430 of them each each of them
their their jurisdictions would vote
like 700 000 people that that one guy
represents would vote and you'd get
either yes or no and then that would be
that one 430th of the total because
every section would because when we send
a representative to congress they get
access to classified intelligence that
can't go to the public for which they
can make it's a lot of trust to put in a
person and we have to i don't know
because they get corrupted it's it's
corruption exists but doesn't mean every
single person uh you know who gets into
congress is evil though i certainly
don't like most of them that's that's
fair and they're cool when they come in
a lot of them are
they sound like it well but you know
what i'm telling you that's why
think about also leaving aside you know
a certain kind of person is attracted to
power there's a lot of power there so
you're going to get a certain elected
class of people
the first thing you do when you have to
when you get into office is you got to
start running for re-election and what
what is required to run for re-election
well you have to make nice with your
party leadership because they're going
to support you if you fundraise for them
if you do not fundraise for them they
will get you axed so
all the incentives
will corrupt almost any man unless you
are so wealthy or so powerful or so
famous and thus you don't really care
and you know that you've got a
constituency the other it's tough to
buck the system i mean it's like trump
going up against bureaucracy is where 99
of the people hate his guts how do you
win in a situation like that very
difficult the other thing is once you
get in once you're in office
the the party establishment says do it
do what we want or else and then if you
say i won't do it they'll say well then
we'll just seed some negative stories
into local press so that you never run
you never win again i think we just need
someone to be like i'm here for two
years and i'm not going to do any of
that stuff i don't care we need people
who aren't like aoc man she folded
really really quickly she got criticized
for the left because as soon as she got
elected she like her positions on israel
and palestine receded dramatically like
she was very very anti-israel to start
now she's only somewhat but there were a
lot of leftists being like her position
totally flipped she was a hardcore
activist and now she's like well i
honestly i don't know a whole lot
because as soon as she got in they were
like if you screw with us you're done
now think about this aoc was a bartender
and i have no disrespect for her for
being a bartender i'm actually very
impressed with a bartender saying i want
to represent this district and and
winning that's that's amazing america's
awesome
but however think about what happens to
a person when you go from being a nobody
a bartender and now you've got millions
of fans
and you lose your re-election because
when when she got elected they were
talking about drawing out her district
so that she wouldn't have anywhere to
run they were talking about primarying
her because she was
raucous she was rocking the boat now she
pretty much falls in line now
and she doesn't lose what she's got
because if she doesn't get real if she
didn't get reelected because they
primaried her or took away her district
what would she be again she would be an
activist she'd be okay she'd do well
she's famous
but this is her thing this is her life
she finally matters
she doesn't want to lose that so of
course nancy pelosi says you get in line
or you're out and she says yes ma'am
so they get in and they immediately
start running for reflection oh that
the first rule is when the second rule
is get elected re-elected and then after
that you you start caring about maybe
the positions that you really hold near
and dear and also by the way how are you
going to get those committee assignments
that you want to cover the issues that
you really care about well who who hands
out the committee assignments yep the
leadership and if the american
population did it through vote that
would that be less
less valuable well even decided the
practicality issue of like yeah
classified information and all the other
stuff that they have access to that it
would be a danger to the if if everyone
had access to it
i mean the founders would say direct
democracy is far more dangerous than the
representative system because direct
democracy is just tyranny of the
majority and it can change every day
yeah and and then it's you know sort of
like what joe biden is saying like well
if public opinion comes around vaccine
passports which also an important thing
to point out is
yes the congress is largely useless and
yes the things that they do do are
horrible but then the issues where they
actually should put things to a vote and
legislate because as a rep as
representatives of us they always punt
the actually difficult decisions to the
supreme court right to a president or to
the administrative state where they pass
a law they don't really fill in the
details and then some bureaucrat who is
unelected who you have no control over
whatsoever is unfireable
is actually going to be the one who's
really making the law because at the end
of the day it's the regulators and all
the bureaucrats and the agencies who
actually make and execute the laws
so they'll pass vague laws and then have
corporations
uh define those in practice not
corporations regulators you know all the
all the different the myriad alphabet
soup of agencies you know they'll say
and we delegate this authority to xyz
agency to craft the details of it so
it's even further removed that's the
deep state or the the either or the
shadow government i don't know the
difference administrative state deep
state okay the unelected deep the state
within the state the state within the
state that actually
deals makes the sausage wild that's
what's going on think about this i mean
you you could do it run for office win
and then say i would like to audit the
fed and then all of a sudden some
intelligence agency just happens to leak
some bad information on you and now you
can't get re-elected
or you get removed from all your
committee assignments and things like
that
so deep state call it whatever you want
chuck schumer said it would get you six
waves from sunday oh yeah he did
recently
first of all it's just or it's just
orwellian that a u.s senator actually
says that but i guess he was being
honest yeah so
that's right so we're electing people to
become puppets
you know it's funny how we we talk about
the chinese communist party and i don't
see a big difference between the the the
shadow government the deep the the
permanent i think they call the
permanent government that's what who
said that somebody was testifying for
commerce i said the deep state is
conspiracy term conspiracy term we call
it the permanent government these are
people who are appointed to positions
where they're there for multiple uh
administrations and they're the ones who
give the advice
and effectively control what the
president or or the administration is
going to do because you'll go this way
you get you get a high ranking
intelligence officer
and then you know obama gets in office
and he says you know i campaigned on
pulling out of iraq he says well
actually you can't because of that and
he goes you got it do your thing he says
you got it trump was special because
trump came and went no
we're getting out i don't care and
they're like but look i don't care we're
pulling out and i think that's why they
were immediately like this guy's got to
go
because there are people who have been
planning what's going on in in north
africa in the middle east probably for
decades or at least a century probably
then trump comes in and they're like see
here's why you gotta get do what we're
telling you to do and trump was like
well i was gonna do it but now you're
telling me i don't want to
look at how hard it is to declassify a
document you think well it's the
president of the united states he can
declassify whatever he wants oh but it's
got to go through several layers of
review and then it's gonna be reviewed
by the lawyers and then and then
someone's gonna at the same time be a
whistleblower against you and concoct
something to try to get an impeachment
going or we're gonna have russiagate the
entire time of your presidency to tank
your policy for a couple years but even
this is the problem with people like uh
when you get a trump trump doesn't want
to jump on the grenade figuratively uh
so i mean he could have been like i'm
gonna do a state of the union and then
just pull the documents and like i will
now start reading
and because he's the president he can
but the bureaucracy jams it up they
defied his orders they lied to the
american people they lied to him when he
trusted these people to do what he he
ordered them to do they just didn't and
then they waited him out what they're
ordered to and by law also you know they
always talk about the rule uh you know
the democratic institutions and and how
we care so much about the institutions
and the integrity and this is an
authoritarian strongman you had his
subordinates who are supposed to serve
him and he serves the constitution as
our representative
basically saying no we disagree with you
and we're going to act accordingly and
we're going to snipe you and backstab
you and do all these things i mean
people talk these generals out there
essentially
admittedly played shell games with
number of troops in syria and they say
that in articles
that is the most about it how disturbing
is that you have generals outwardly
flouting the commander in chief right
there it's very because that's a
precedent that's for the next time that
they don't want to do what the president
says what our commander
our elected commander decides it's just
all falling apart man
that on election
i'll be honest i was i jokingly said
this but maybe it's more true i said
there hasn't really been in america
since the jekyll island conspiracy yeah
the
i wonder how how can i cause i think
about the british opium wars with china
because there's been like the five eyes
you know it's like britain australia the
united states new zealand they said they
would poke they said they would poke
at least one of the five eyes out if you
dare go against them that was their the
communist party rhetoric
and then the formation of israel seems
very much like that was part of that
organization to put like kind of an
outpost by the suez canal and like have
a have a front post in the middle east
for all the resources and stuff like
with the way they betrayed the ottomans
in world war one in the arabs to well
they betrayed the arabs they told the
arabs we're gonna give you all this land
then at the end of the in the middle of
the war they're like actually thanks for
betraying the ottomans for us arabs
thanks for helping us win world war one
we're not giving you the land we're
going to create israel instead and then
after world war ii yeah world war one
right the underworld the balfour
declaration and it there's been a lot of
resent but it's like this obsessed
obsessive
colonial it's been going on since like
the 1400s since like the 1600s this
colonialization
now it's in afghanistan
and they're using the american military
now like i don't know if it's
the king if it was the british king all
along if or if there's like banks above
him that are
do you have feelings on having
aliens
maybe it's the aliens controlling the
dmt and the systems and
we're all just chickens in a chicken
coop man
they're just you know moving the cages
around for the chickens
i wonder if
if this
i don't know moving to coop it's
definitely the bread the british have a
lot of hands in like they colonize india
they colonized the west bank area with
with israel they call it you know they
tried to colonize china all of it they
wanted it
when you hear chuck schumer say
something like we got you six ways from
sunday it makes me wonder about whether
or not what we do as an impact because
what's that old saying if voting
mattered they wouldn't let you do it
you know
you counts the votes
yeah yeah didn't biden say that
recently yeah yeah originally he said it
doesn't it's not about who uh who votes
about who counts the vote in the end
it's like i i don't know who originally
said that quote i think was falsely
attributed to stalin though but it's
still a creepy prospect
hey that's welcome welcome to modern
america i suppose
it's not bad you know we're born into a
country it feels almost like what
they're saying to us is you live in a
wealthy country enjoy it while you can
or else
you know don't don't rock the boat don't
challenge us we do what we want
and the wealth isn't the only i mean the
wealth is
a byproduct
of us being able to pursue our happiness
in freedom do what we want achieve
greatness however we define it
the wealth is just is the end game
output it might happen and it might not
but if you're you know if you have
ingenuity and you have a pioneering
instinct and you have risk takers and
such then wealth is ultimately going to
result from it but wealth isn't the ult
is not the purpose of this whole thing
it's about letting people achieve what
they want to achieve
and make their own little kingdom on
earth for themselves and we're getting
further and and further away from that i
should also add it's called the sykes
pico agreement was what the official
document that formed israel against the
arab will that was
it's
so it seems it comes from a a feeling of
lack like
since since the dawn of time they've
been afraid there weren't enough
resources so we need to
make sure we have enough for our people
and
and and now that we're realizing like
with with quantum computing and
atom molecular printing that maybe there
is enough materials like maybe we can
just print water out of air with enough
electricity
you still need the mass in the matter
and you can disrupt the balance of the
ecosystem very easily so they have to do
asteroid mining or a moon base or
something
in star trek they collect hydrogen with
the
with the ship as they fly through it and
then they use that as the mass for the
replicators
um ben how do you feel about
releasing like classified documents
uh well from my perspective sun white is
the best disinfectant and
the more transparency to a large extent
the better this is obviously tough
because we're talking
in generalities here and it's what is
the substance of the classified
documents obviously
but that said based upon what
all of the how many times during the
trump administration was it well you
know this this might reveal uh sensitive
sources and and get someone killed
essentially if we released it and then
you find out when they finally do
unredact that actually no it was just
protecting the people who are engaging
in corrupt behavior or potentially
illegal behavior so it's tough because i
am a staunchly believe in defending our
national security to the death and
acting in accordance with our national
interest on the other hand you see them
abuse nationalist security it justify so
many different things so the general
matter like i want everything around
russiagate and spy gate declassified and
a whole host of other things from
history too i mean
it should all be out there and if it's
not it's probably because there's some
pretty powerful interests who don't want
it to be exposed for one reason or
another it looks bad it undermines them
that's why julian assange ends up locked
up for a decade didn't they just
overturn some movement he was trying to
put forth a couple days ago did you guys
see that they're never gonna let that
guy out even even after the the swedish
investigation was ended they're like no
he can't leave and then they're like
there's no reason to hold them anymore
and then
the us comes out with their indictment
it's just
i tell you man that's i think that's
evidence right they will they will
accuse you of the worst of the worst and
then they will lock you up to the best
of their abilities and destroy your life
according to the guardian steve bell and
a uk judge backing the u.s appeal in
julian assange's extradition case so
they they wait they backed it the uk
judge backed the u.s appeal in the
extradition case right so they're going
to actually him
yeah it looks i mean they're that's what
they want you know what they should do
release him
yeah that's not gonna happen though
maybe or uh and i mean what could happen
epstein so if we really want to go down
this rabbit hole yeah but also the j6
thing
talk about the people in the dc jail
and the government has said that they
have evidence that would be potentially
exculpatory they won't admit it
and it's not out there yet and you know
there's 14 000 hours of footage and you
know they just don't have the logistical
capabilities to build the database that
people can look at so that a lawyer can
defend a client and of course you know
the left in any other instance would be
oh this is the civil liberties abuse of
the century but really the process is
the punishment let's say that people who
really were just engaging in trespassing
no violence whatsoever and they were and
they were let in by a security guard end
up walking at the end of the day still
think about how much punishment there
will have been in the months that you're
waiting to have your case dealt with and
if you're held in pre-trial detention
and a lot of these people some of them
have psychological issues some of them
are not hardened criminals and don't
have any rap sheet whatsoever and you're
stuck in this jail how does it and then
you have the judges and the prosecutors
also saying essentially well your views
about what happened in that election
make you a potential danger if we let
you out so we're not gonna let you out
it's just it's beyond disturbing and
like the assange example is an extreme
example obviously but these are people
who
again they're not hardened criminals in
in many respects and the process is the
punishment and this sends a warning this
sends a warning to anyone you know don't
dissent essentially from the party one
and again you're going to be cast as
well you're an insurrectionist enabler
and supporter and no that that's not it
it's i believe in justice and i believe
people should be treated equally under
the law watch the uh i've been shouting
this out it's like the eighth time watch
electric dreams on amazon and the the
last episode uh it's the last episode
it's called kill all others
and uh the simple synopsis for those i
know most of you listening probably
heard me say a million times but
basically this guy hears a politician
say that you know the people need to
kill all others and he gets shocked by
it and starts telling people like no no
i don't know that's about we shouldn't
advocate for violence and they go
who cares what are you and other and he
was like what is another anyway and
they're like i don't know but you seem
pretty defensive and then it escalates
anybody who opposes the party line is
called they must be another
and then people start getting violent
towards the others it's really really
it's a it's a really interesting episode
how they laid it out i thought it's
fascinating uh let's go to super chats
oh yeah if you have not already please
give that like button a little little uh
tap
do it for ian yeah
do it for me and then when we get a
chance to dive into the matrix and fix
this from the inside let's go
right now there is a a sad ian who is
waiting for your like and simply by
pressing that like you could make the
day of an ian today it's true all right
uh and go to teamcast.com be a member
and uh let's read what we got here uh
born again says shout out to baby bonnet
box
for usa handmade baby bonnets
okay very cool that sounds awesome i
look that up
all right let's see
instructions for interplanetary visitors
says tim did you see that video of the
doctor talking about the delta variant
making kids sick and she starts breaking
into laughter bizarre i did not see that
huh interesting
i don't have you guys seen that
no just the other video that twitter
swapped the warning on what millions of
people saw was it
just a doctor
speaking
what he believed to be the open and
honest truth about
various things around coronavirus and it
went viral of course and thus you had to
swap was it recent
yeah oh well in the last week
mussy moose says did you guys see
desantis pushing monoclonal antibody
treatment to help people expose to covet
going so far as to make task forces and
centers for it this is the same kind of
treatment trump used regeneron i did not
hear about that i did see something
about that yeah
didn't read much it's worth saying one
of the
scandals around
coronavirus generally besides how lab
league went from conspiracy theory to
suddenly all the acceptable people think
it's acceptable yeah early treatment
also was dismissed immediately and then
over time suddenly it became somewhat
acceptable who is anyone going to answer
for the fact that like that was
poo-pooed completely and now all of a
sudden it's okay
uh does the media ever answer for
putting out garbage i mean russiagate
come on you know i i love uh you ever
see that collection of bombshell
bombshell the beginning of the end the
walls are closing in bombshell bombshell
wow these people are unscrupulous
dragon lady says
i live on the ohio michigan border there
are tons of local roads that cross that
border we have a cop shortage and
they're going to pull cops off the
street to main to man checkpoints or
will biden use that as an excuse to send
in the military to do it am i being
paranoid i don't think they'll actually
do it but i certainly think you'd be a
fool not to remain vigilant in paying
attention because who knows what they're
capable of doing to be completely honest
all right kyle miller says i have a
feeling that kabul is going to be the
saigon of our generation yep wow oh wow
i'm seeing it and that's where where
they tried to pull the troops out right
but they
was there a slaughter in saigon i don't
know
it was vietnamese south vietnamese city
saigon was the north vietnamese southern
vietnamese
evacuating people the helicopter the
imagery and indelible imagery i'm sure
there will be some
equivalent here but this is really like
kind of the ultimate ruling class
exercise the way every aspect of the way
that afghanistan is played out i mean we
can talk about it but
yeah go in
don't have clear objectives of what
victory looks like or reasonable
objectives of what victory looks like
turning switz afghanistan into
switzerland not knowing any of the
history of any other power going into
afghanistan like if the soviet union
couldn't do it you probably can either
and i know by the way why should you try
to
and then the way that it was executed
for years and the untruths told about it
and the trillions of dollars wasted and
lives wasted and then we leave the
strongest power in the world and then
within two weeks it falls
yep
someone commented before that they
didn't even think that the afghan
security forces even wanted to fight the
taliban they were just like okay
america's gone all right guys come on in
here's our guns
sarah a says while biden is thinking
about a mandatory facts for interstate
travel liberal party of canada just did
it you all need some hard-working
canadians
yeah
come on down man down here let's unify
canadians and cubans will not be allowed
by the bite administration i'm sure
cool papa zulu says tim with your huge
presence please start the mayo bucket
challenge for people to donate to their
favorite local restaurant to help offset
their rising costs i'm going to the
sherwood tomorrow save the local diners
um well i don't know if you need to
donate just go buy their food
go there and be like i'd like to
purchase your where is good sir and then
buy them and then they succeed so leave
a good yelp review while you're at it
yeah leave a good yelp review at the
restaurants you like just to offset this
insanity and i got to tell you onto the
sherwood's website their food looks real
good but i'm not north carolina so i'm
going to be trying it anytime soon
all right
quiet guitarist fan says took care of
someone last night who had been bounced
back and forth to the icu with the beer
virus they were vaccinated mandates
would do nothing to create nothing but
create a divisive system and destroy any
sense of unity between people
and i think it breeds mistrust that's
the craziest thing you know
what what did someone say um
i remember i can't remember exactly we
mentioned it before but it's like
if their approach to kovid had been
hey get it when you can the vaccination
would probably be way higher but they've
created this mistrust in people by doing
these really weird things like bonuses
and lotteries and then threats and
mandates now you've got people just
defying you for the sake of defying you
because they're bored and the
flip-flopping fouchy's flip-flopping the
cdc's flip-flopping like they didn't
know was going on but they were giving
authoritative advice off of
misinformation basically their own
misinformation
going back to the lockdowns themselves
remember the imperial college models
millions of people are going to die if
we don't do this and they were garbage
in garbage out models and it's like you
would think there'd be some humility
among people in the scientific community
to say well we really don't know and
here's our best judgment and we're going
to take try to take a prudent approach
instead it's the every single time it's
the jackhammer it's not the scalpel yep
david kacianowicz says tim i noticed you
wear the same outfit do you have other
clothes
uh technically yes but you'll also
notice i only wear this on this show if
you watch my other shows i'm wearing
different clothes indeed so then i put
on these for this show and then take
them off right away yeah it's brand new
but uh i don't wear the clothes watch
the cast castle vlog at youtube.com cast
castle and i'm always wearing different
clothes oh look at that new episode
going up going up this weekend right
cool yeah i think it might be sunday and
then because we're trying to transition
into daily so there's a workflow being
built you guys got to see kent leon
welling's animation on the cast castle
vlogs this guy's a master it's always
really really fun his anime ken make
more anime i want to turn you into anime
21st century anime artist
he's so good all right chris meagley
says standing up for small business the
rising gas prices are killing our little
lawn care business plus i wanted to hear
our name shout out shout out on my
favorite show knc mowing's knc mowing
service live oak florida very cool there
you go man thanks for the super chat
sim yang says twin cities cub foods gets
rid of sp police department and hires
peace activists who beats a homeless
asian man because he stole something
gestapo wow wait what really wow did you
guys hear that portland all the
businesses are hiring private security
now oh my gosh makes sense and the joke
now is that it's in kappa stan
it's it's it's gone so anarchic that now
people are just hiring their own private
police departments that's the beauty of
of decentralized command is we'll get to
see now we get to watch what happens
when businesses start hiring private
security
what do we expect
whoa what is this
first amendment says got stabbed eight
times at 17 and shot by a 12 gauge at
22. what thankful for socialized
healthcare but my views are far right in
canada 27 and making more positive
decisions mad respect for the tim cass
team wow man wow jesus you made it i'm
glad you're alive
christopher noll says our domestic and
foreign problems oddly mirror one
another american citizens don't want war
but foreign and domestic threats want
america's collapse trump and biden woke
up the normies big uh-oh my dad voted
for the first time in 20 years for biden
i'm saying that's that's that's that's
right i know a lot of people that i was
shocked to find were in politics
people posting videos and i'm like what
like
these are the kind of people that i'd be
like hey did you guys see i don't want
to hear about it but don't you know you
know brett kevin i'm who
and then all of a sudden they're like
yay biden what do you think what do you
think was the
what kind of the unifying themes for why
biden was the guy they took away all
entertainment all sports so people
didn't have anything to communicate you
couldn't go outside you couldn't go to
the bar you couldn't talk to your
friends and and twitter and facebook and
youtube are dominated by political
conversations so all of these normies
were all of a sudden thrust into a world
where the only way they could socialize
was in this political context in a
political election cycle and they were
you know posting their selfies for biden
i think that that drove a large portion
of it i also think that can explain why
there was there was less down ballot
voting
a lot of people want to think it's
nefarious i think there's two big things
to consider for one
the the the mass exodus from cities due
to covet what half a million people from
new york we don't know how that would
have affected bellwethers certainly i
think the anomalies weren't
investigation certainly i think we
should we should do the audience so
audit so we can build confidence back
between the american people
but i think i think you can explain it
i'm not saying i can it's proof i'm just
saying you know there's an explanation
um but i genuinely think that a lot of
dumb people who don't care about
politics just wanted that sticker so
they could be part of something because
they were locked in their homes
they needed it you know and i think that
was part of uh the democrats
exploitation they were but you got to
look back to like october 2019 when the
republicans made universal mail in
voting in pennsylvania which which very
very much helped democrats
right so they they're republicans at the
unit party right
goodland cruising says capitalism sold
out the country to communists we need a
collective front against our enemies
libertarian ideals fail consistently
nationalism is the answer we must win by
any means necessary defeat is death
uh it's tough i don't know man
it's how do you you look independent
voters
many of them probably vote libertarian
republicans they both recognize a lot of
the same problems
yet they're not going to unify the left
is just walking in lockstep so
yeah we have intellectual diversity and
you know we can have a debate about any
of a million issues but the other side
you know where they're going to end up
every single time even when they
contradict themselves they just march in
line behind ideas that change every
other day did you see that ben shapiro
on bill maher talking to that guy larry
malcolm nance
malcolm was just like not really making
points and then he insulted ben like
your show must suck and it was like this
is this guy's and they were clapping
yeah and they kept clapping and they
were like oh the interview is so much
better without the clapping seals
clapter every five minutes every minute
that was really disappointing that he
didn't really have much of an argument
he didn't really even seem to understand
what the critical race theory was and
that was i think that's a big part of
the problem right now and what we're
seeing is the infection of it in our
society in our in our blood vessels of
our infrastructure and then now we're
starting to see an immune response which
starts slowing then it extrapolates
outward happens exponentially
that's how disease works too a body's
fights off disease so
it feels like that's that's happening is
people start to learn what it is
all right let's see
joshua ryman says keep your head up and
keep pushing forward tim don't cry it's
not over until it's over and even then
as long as i'm alive it's not over keep
going on tim and never give up that's
right never give up never surrender
that's right millennial cop says love
the show
thanks everyone for all you do us needs
to get back into country uh back in back
to in-country manufacturing large scale
people need something in their life to
become a part of a part of and be paid
ending the moratoriums can't happen fast
enough
yes or they could learn to code right
that's a solution because you know a 50
year old pipe fitter certainly knows how
to just just jump on a computer and
start learning computer code which
he can master in a day you know the
other thing about that leave aside the
strategic imperative to you have to be
able to produce certain things
domestically or you're going to be
beholden to potentially your worst
adversaries
i used to take the kind of textbook
economics of you know if you're more
efficient at this then you trade away
your less efficient things and
ultimately
you know kind of like
what's more efficient ultimately is
better for the greater good even if that
means certain industries die over time
we have creative destruction etc
but the thing that isn't discussed in
the creative destruction is
what if that destruction leads to
generational consequences that far dwarf
that immediate economic loss to a
particular place and what does that do
in terms of like having a cohesive
country that's actually together
and that wasn't something that i thought
about when i was you know the economics
student or whatever but i do think about
today and why i give some more credence
to
some protectionist instincts that i
would not have had in the past leaving
aside the strategic imperative that you
got to be able to produce certain things
100 in america and you have to be able
to like produce all your medicines and
at least our medicines
at very minimum you got to have medicine
food yeah and the like food yeah kind of
crazy slightly important
all right steven heinold says has ian
ever been hit by lightning because if so
it would be like a less cool marvel
origin story of a hippie and really
explain a lot about him no but i've got
an even better origin story i was uh
meditating on my couch and my brother
was across the room and i was looking in
his eyes we were looking at each other
and this lightning or whatever was
electricity shot down through my head
and into him like into my head and then
out my eyes struck my life and he jolted
and i said i'm so sorry like it felt
like i used the dark side of the force
and i i was like i'll never do that
again people don't understand that uh
when when ian first arrived here he was
wearing a suit he had short hair and he
was clean-shaven radicalized and he was
he was no actually what happened was he
had come and he was
he was selling uh uh uh milkshake mixers
uh you know just a traveling salesman
clean cut for his wife and child and
then as he was standing on my porch i
was like you know i could use a
milkshake mixer a bolt of lightning hit
him burned his clothes in his hair he
immediately started growing out and he
started screaming
and then he told me that he could see
the wolf hominids tearing down his
magnetic fields which is true
and uh promo code poso there you go
[Laughter]
it was intense it was a slow lightning
bolt i think it's still hitting me
that's possibly going off like 20 years
that's a lot
a lot
it actually explained that there's like
an electrical imbalance in ian's head
that's all
honestly i started making youtube videos
in 2006 and really like letting my
myself out letting my secrets out being
very personable and honest
and i started to feel energy coming like
when people walk i think what's
happening is when someone's watching
your videos
it it feeds you energy because they're
picturing you so it's like sending you
energy maybe through the schumann
resonance or something but i started to
get this like invigoration of energy in
this like
24 7. because your videos are being
watched at all times of the day
very weird and sure that wasn't the
vaccine i still haven't figured it out
it may be relaxing
what is this zach kruger says hey tim
check out the a uh the at
you said aft is it atf atf's new rule
saying if your ar-15 has a trigger it
equals now a machine gun
what check out mr guns and gears video
on it i would not be surprised
fascinating james rogers says i'm in the
navy and today our command announced
that sec deaf will make coven 19 vaccine
mandatory by september 15th for all
service members
you know i and i hear that but i i said
this before like don't people in the
service just get a bunch of vaccines as
it is
i do yeah so i'm like why is this one
controversial because they're they're
all fda approved it's got to be fda
approved maybe yeah yeah i guess i
understand all that i'm just like if you
sign up you sign
aren't you government property now isn't
that how it works
rules are different public employee
private employee but increasingly those
blind those
lines are blurred when you have the
administration saying like we're meeting
with businesses and we're encouraging
you to incentivize your
employees get vaccinated
all right
jesse meek says everyone is concerned by
this some of the best youtube channels
are discussing it we were having a
heated discussion referencing much of
the same sources over on liberty doll's
stream minutes ago sleeping bear is
waking interesting
shredkowski says bought your gorilla
shirt a few months ago people at my work
love it without knowing the context
hoping to build a gorilla army and build
culture that's right we have a whole
bunch of different i am a gorilla shirts
for some reason we just kept making we
have the the the dogecoin one i think is
really funny oh yeah
yep
all right
scarier three says the in the interior
flight thing with aliens has been a
thing since the beginning and it's
happened before biden back in early 2019
whenever a family unit one adult with
one child minimum arrives they are given
a court date to see a judge
interesting
and then there's another one many do not
show up to court right huge majority
scarier says
uh there we go it's the law on books
normally they'd be held until then but
when they run out of space you can't
send them back so they'd be sent to a
family
a family member address wherever in the
u.s to wait for court
can't send them back as a family and the
left and aliens are aware of this same
thing with unaccompanied juveniles the
loophole has been here for a while it's
just now that the admin doesn't care
about optics
very very interesting
dc pagan says tim when will the beanies
come i will pay serious money for your
trade marcobini i will wear it
everywhere we have tried actually uh
spring what used to be teespring
tried sourcing beanies like this it's
impossible
we've gone to i've looked i've talked to
a bunch of different companies and they
just can't do it and i'm like where did
this one come from and i we reach out to
the company nope won't do it
so weird yep
looks like uh we i mean it's certainly
something we've been trying i told we
had someone here and they were like why
are you selling beanies and i was like
i'll tell you what you figure out how to
do it and you can get a cut and they
were like yes and then they gave up
after a month we're talking about
weaving silver throughout the beanie
antibacterial yeah
yep
all right let's see
rasgriz says the best way to get rid of
the power and in enrichment incentive
isn't to remove it it's to exploit it
tie their salary given to the median
income of the district they represent if
they enrich their people they enrich
themselves
i've heard that before it sounds
intriguing you know what what do you
think about that
perform performance metrics also uh so
you get a
carrot for that but also some sticks
associated with other policies yes 100
i guess the issue is
you can always just do a favor for a
guaranteed job the big company says you
know this bill's really bad for us don't
worry i got you and then as soon as your
term's over they're like oh that vp
position half a million a year it's all
yours thanks for your for your service
what if your initial salary was zero and
it for every amount you could lower the
deficit you would get a proportional
incentively you know basically because
then it would just be rich people who
have the means to run who don't more
people that are want to rip down the
federal reserve immediately because it's
a ponzi scheme and they're like i can't
reduce the deficit if i have to pay
interest on my debt
the only way to get to pay it off is to
take more debt on with more interest
who's going to pass the law to get
people in office who want to reduce the
debt and deficits and also does the
public broadly want to reduce debt and
deficits they might pull yes but then
you go to them okay let's talk about a
specific project in your district that's
gone
and then we're also going to slash this
program and this program and that
program
oh if you present it that way to the
public at what at what point does the
public say you know what the short-term
pain is worth it because we have
generational generational generational
theft and our interest is soon going to
be even greater than the size of our
budget right it's like exercise like how
do you incentivize people to do things
that hurt in the short term for
long-term benefit and the politicians
will say well it's going to happen on
someone else's watch so because they
won't get reelected if they're blamed
for the one to be the one that hurts
them right weird system all right brian
weaver says great job everyone we need
to fully learn the lessons of of
trustlessness from the blockchain and
apply these to our government systems
smart contracts could be a powerful
vehicle to hold politicians accountable
necessarily
perhaps i just don't know
man and i've thought about this a lot
how do you solve it we have a really
good system but it's just i guess thomas
jefferson put it well that you know like
every 200 years or so you'll get that
bloat or whatever and there's got to be
some kind of like renewal i guess i
don't know if he used those words uh he
certainly used some words but i think we
come to a point where like there have
been periods where we've just voted out
all the incumbents
you know i think it was like in the 50s
that happened it was like congress got
like just
purged everyone was like we don't want
any of these people who want different
people we need something like that i
don't think that ultimately solves all
the problems though i think one of the
great things about america is that
decentralized power makes it very
difficult for establishment elites to to
gain all that power
but i think right now we are witnessing
the point where power has coalesced to a
degree where they can maintain it
forever when when they
got all those incumbents out office you
know what year that was no i remember
looking at some graph about um uh
democrat republican party size and stuff
and there was something in i think the
50s was that's like right after the
military industrial complex got formed
like did they perform a coup
no people were out like i was reading
the news about it people were really
upset with congress there was like
really low improvement i wonder if it
was propaganda and they were getting the
old guard out and putting in all these
new
i don't know man jekyll island was what
1903 or something
1916-17 i think was 12 1912 maybe 12.
yeah is that what happened i mean
it's it's an interesting game to play
when did the demise start
is it the income tax and uh the federal
reserve is it nixon taking us off the
gold standard officially is it the
frankfurt school
denizens arriving in the united states
when was that
1930s
then there was the the liberal economic
order in 1946 that was like that's
pretty pretty nasty right after world
war ii that's military police but you
know at the end of the day i it is the
greatest system
ever created bar none in my view but it
requires a people to sustain it
and you look at countries that have
had their freedom taken away from them
and then they come back they hold to it
in a tighter way than people who we've
had it good at least on paper for a very
long time and we haven't faced that
threat or felt what tyranny was like
here and i think as a consequence
you get bloated and you set yourself up
for
potentially a fall but the sun comes up
the next day so
all right john
how do i pronounce that christian
christian
where has the gray-bearded man of wisdom
jack murphy been well my friends he is
in a better place
yeah where is that i don't know he's
around
arizona
jack's doing stuff with his family he is
living practicing what he preaches so
good for him what up jack yeah all right
alexander scarpecci says i love the
animation on cast castle the animation
along with the narration cracks me up i
want more you guys if you haven't
checked out cass castle you are missing
out so it's just like there's there's
always some really funny story or
exposition or something kent will then
animate something funny and it's just
it's really funny i think the first one
he did was when we went to the casino
with sheamus
and the story is really simple we were
like we played for a long time i was
kind of done i'm like i'm just putting
all my money down in this last hand and
we all ended up with like really crappy
hands i had like 13 alison had like you
know 15 or whatever sheamus i think had
13 and then andreas had like 12 and and
but the dealer was showing i think he
was showing a five
it's been a long time you watch the
story but i was like everyone stay cause
he'll likely flip a face card then hit
and bust
sheamus
so the dealer's looking at us and he's
like he looks at me and i'm like staying
he's like i know he looks oh you're
going to stay then he goes to champions
and james goes i'm going to hit and then
we're all like what no why don't don't
and then he gets uh
what did he get i can't remember exactly
what he got but he gets a card and then
uh he doesn't bust and we're like oh
okay the dealer ends up flipping over
not a face card but like a four
and then he ends up getting a queen so
he gets 19 and then he beats all of us
we all lose our money and if uh sheamus
didn't
hit the dealer would have grabbed that
card and then busted on the queen
so we were all like no and that's we
animated the story it's really funny
because you know did you did you tell
sheamus beforehand don't hit i was like
everyone yep oh man contrarian and
there's a little drawing of me going
don't hit don't hit i was like stay stay
it's really funny it's really funny and
the dealer is just like
and then seamus leans back and his eyes
are half closed and he goes i'm gonna
hit yeah and we're like no why did you
hit
and then sheamus commented on the video
i'm glad i did it
of course he did
well
he pushed so he got to keep his money
all right let's see
ski man from toronto
says
hey tim and crew love the show trudeau
pushing for snap national election and
mandating vaccines for all federal
employees slow stepping our way to full
mandates no medical autonomy left north
or south of the border
yep yeah i think um
i i you know we had the lockdowns
everyone hated it
now they have lockdowns again unless you
get the vaccine
so what are people gonna do
you know it's it's it's like hey you
don't want that that awful thing to
happen again do you
so people are just gonna fall in line i
think it'll expand across the country
it's gonna do it slowly it's just it's
just so disturbing that we're at a place
where it's like the government is saying
we wanna make people feel pain and also
we are going to create this bifurcated
society of the vaxxed and the unvaxed
and there was a new york times headline
i have to find it several months back
where it was like
far right stop the steal moves on to vax
hesitancy you know something like that
and it just flows so seamlessly and
actually if you look the department of
homeland security put out uh i think one
of their latest terror bulletins today i
screenshotted this on my twitter and
they say covet 19 uh you know skepticism
etc could lead to violence over the next
x months
and so again public health national
security they will tie the two
together it's one in the same stop this
deal through vaccine hesitancy here's a
good one uh
twmy says i don't usually hit the like
button but the other day said would you
kindly smash that like button and
without even thinking i demolished it
coincidence oh
hey hey everybody
would you kindly tap that like button
uh do you get you know i do now yes oh
you looked it up no you told me about it
once on the show do you know the
reference bioshock bioshock have you
played bioshock before it's it's a
really i know the game i haven't played
20 minutes of it i tried to play it on
hard and it was like it's too hard so
amazing
amazing game uh basically the character
is compelled to take any action if you
say would you kindly before the request
so i am trying to compel all of you to
would you kindly
press that like button
and then a lot of people were like
bioshock reference yeah and then they
all start smashing the like button like
all right i'll just figure out cool
easter eggs to throw in with asking
people to tap the light to press the
like button and so then people will be
like yay and they'll you know
alex one eleven thousand says tim did
you hear about apple scanning your
phones in the claim of child
exploitation and the new [ __ ] crypto and
infrastructure build taxes a little bit
about the crypto stuff um i'm not super
worried about that the apple spyware
stuff that is
like if it's a red flag the size of the
state of texas being raised above
everybody they always try to use
something that is that no one would ever
want to be against like oh but i mean
it's only for child exploitation right
you're not for well
nobody is it's disgusting
but you want a private company to start
scanning my my my media
and i'm supposed to just trust you no
i'm not playing that game you're crazy
i'll be like we're going to scan
people's thoughts but only for child
porn
yeah right you're building the
technology to be able to scan people's
thoughts okay you're setting a precedent
that you can do it you get an eye what
else can you scan it for you get an
android phone you put on a more secure
operating system you don't let people
spin the freedom phone which we still
haven't broken apart yet but there's all
sorts of do you news other than apple we
need to get the freedom fund we do that
forensic analysis i have a feeling we're
not going to find anything i think it's
going to be just like a very
straightforward phone that does what it
says it does you know the crypto thing
i'm curious what you guys think about
that do you think that the targeting of
crypto is ultimately
a mafia-like extortion strategy of let's
threaten crypto and then we'll get
something out of them and they'll pay us
to go away or do you think that
ultimately
they want into the game like the
government wants a piece of it they want
to be able to extract maximum revenues
from it or
what do you think the end game is
the globalists have created bitcoin as
the one world currency um
bitcoin is the perfect globalist
currency
how do you implement a a unified global
currency when you have a whole group of
anti-government individuals claiming
it's a conspiracy
you make them pro it
and they're the ones who push it then
all the institutions adopt it and now
they have their inter you know country
financial system being put in place it
strikes me that they're trying to make
as much money extract as much revenue
out of it as possible because it
coincides with biden um i think he's
been investing in the irs and wants to
start
uh helping these irs to basically get
more tax make sure that people are
paying their taxes you get all these
unemployment checks going out those
people are gonna have to pay taxes on
those so i think they're looking at
taxation as the way to recover help
recover from this i want to read
one more turk longwell says for all
listening now
now is the time it's time now we speak
up and out or we lose it's now or it's
never you all do great work thank you
yes
you know i've been saying over and over
again that people need to stand up when
their workplace tries doing this
critical race stuff they should say no
to this they should challenge it and a
lot of people say but i'm scared to lose
my job okay well now they're saying
mandatory
minor but medical procedure
you can
stand up and say you agree with it or
you don't
personally um
the mandating is the problem you know
and i think with i think here's the
thing right vaccines
are uh
i'm impressed by them they're cool i'm
i'm fascinated by george washington the
story where he was they would inoculate
people by taking like the needle and i
think it's fantastic and i think just
like with the apple thing they try to
use things you don't want to be against
you're like i get it this is actually a
good thing it helps people and that's
what they use to open the door towards
authoritarianism so
you got to speak up and defy this stuff
i want to do one last thing real quick
not maybe not even a full segment but i
just want to talk about suicide have you
seen suicide squad
i have not negative
okay i'll just talk a little bit because
there was one thing i wanted to mention
and then we'll just we'll talk for a
couple of minutes
the movie bombed
the movie's bombing and now they're
saying that they're gonna they're gonna
delay the release of the new venom movie
because black widow and suicide squad
bombed wow
something happened people don't care
anymore about what's going on they're
not watching the movies i guess they're
not the money's not going in
like
there's a there's there's a great reset
happening right now
and i think
you know i heard a story the other day
um someone a friend of a friend quit
their job and said i just don't want to
work anymore
and now they're broke and i'm like
that's weird because the great
resignation is happening what's
happening to people where they're like i
don't care i'm happy with being broke
i'm done like this
breakdown whatever it is it's like
it's happening everywhere and more more
people here are just like i'm quitting i
don't care
so you think that the industry's also
kind of quit they've kind of given up
and they're just not being creative
these people are quitting their jobs
they're not going to the movies either
it's like society itself is crumbling
like all these movies are making money
and now it's just like you know a lot of
black widow didn't do well that's a
marvel film they always captain uh
captain marvel got a billion dollars
that's crazy to me to me that kind of
feels like society as a whole is a
little bit depressed which kind of makes
me sad but not really surprised because
after this whole lockdown thing
everyone's like what's the point why
would i carry on which just they hate
capitalism they hate boomers they hate
everything that they work for they hate
the work that they do so they're like i
give up and it's working for them
because of unemployment let me just say
it seems like people are gone yeah i we
entered sort of an age of honesty in the
in 2008 where people were like speaking
out i was one of them on youtube like
look at the world look at the military
industrial complex i didn't know it
existed until today and
so when when you see a pushback we see
people get banned when they're speaking
up honestly against authoritarianism or
establishment politics or whatever
and you see
crap being pushed out that's obviously
not honest like
like when they tell you something's good
when it's not like that's
they tell you a movie like it's a 98
rating but then when you look at the
crowd rates at 37 percent people like
what the [ __ ] it's broken people are
they give up faith they give up hope and
that i want to structure when that
happens we'll end off with just
something to think about
where is everybody
they're not working
they're not going to movies
they're not out in the middle of big
cities
where are they
they're right here
we'll just leave it that you can follow
us at tim cast irl smash that like
button be a member at timcast.com we got
tons of reporting new shows coming you
can follow me personally at tim cast ben
did you want to shout out any social
media yeah at bhwinegarden and uh
subscribe to my newsletter at
winegarden.substance.com
right on follow me ian crossland and ian
crossland.net i want to show you guys
this i've been thinking a lot about this
cultural decay so what i did is i went
out and i bought the six issues of the
infinity gauntlet this is the original
this is where it all came from in the
90s
arguably the infinity gauntlet number
four is the best comic marvel comic ever
made if you want to get excited about
comics and the industry and what it can
be and what it was it could be again get
these get this comic get these comments
great again these are amazing amazing
stories
stan will stand the test of time i
highly recommend and then you'll know
you'll have some perspective on what the
industry what disney did to this
franchise yeah for sure it's funny that
ian mentions that because i've actually
been going through and buying books that
my parents used to read to me when i was
little at a maze book that i really
really loved and i found that online so
i'm just going to kind of like build up
a little library of books from way
before they were woke for if you know if
i ever have kids it'll be awesome before
the books are banned yeah exactly if for
the books are banned before we have to
burn them all anyway you guys can follow
me at sourpatchlids on twitter as i
attempt continue my journey to have more
followers and sour patch kids
go to youtube.com
cast castle subscribe and get ready and
watch all the episodes they're they're
really really well done um the team we
have producing this stuff they're really
great you're going to love all the
animation so check it out and we'll see
you all next time
you